[Applause]
oh you can perfect
[Music]
what's up YouTube my name is dopa Zola
Thomas whatever you want to call me we
are here back with another episode of
the dope as usual podcast I am here with
my co-host Marty O'Neill the [__] is up
guys what's up what's up definitely an
age restrictor off the bat what's up
guys how you doing this is another
episode of the podcast we're here to
talk about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between today is a lot of in between
this is a solo episode just me and Marty
talking [__] to each other and talking
about different stuff I may or may not
have hog legs of joints rolled we'll see
here in a minute uh but we're gonna get
started and the first thing we're gonna
do right off the bat guys before we even
start talking about a topic drop a like
on this video also every week on our
Instagram go ahead boom right over the
screen dope as usual podcast on our
Instagram guys we have been doing
giveaways right now
we're about to announce the winners of
these
right after Josh Wolf left last time we
signed these gigantic posters they're so
sick if you don't follow our Instagram
or Twitter you probably don't get
updated on this
so what we're doing right now guys
is uh announcing the winners so give me
one second let me bust my phone out like
I said I just want to talk about this
before we even get started shout out
everybody that participated too all you
got to do to be entered into these
giveaways is when we prompt everybody on
Instagram drop that handle in a comment
on YouTube so basically what we're doing
is uh say this YouTube video right say
there's a bunch of comments and you see
our posts on Instagram hey we're giving
away a poster we're giving away a merge
we're giving away this you gotta go drop
your Instagram name on the YouTube
channel because we did it before like
drop your
comment on YouTube and then there was no
way to contact you there's no DMS on
YouTube alright so we messed that up
guys so real quick I'm just gonna do
this first the two winners of the
posters this is
Benjamin green stent I said it wrong
always a pleasure listen to you guys
making work make work a lot easier keep
up the good work thank you dude I picked
that one because uh first off you're at
work and we're passing the time for you
that's what we both wished we had when
we first started doing stuff you know
before we started doing uh content I
love that idea so much that's awesome we
are that for people at work the keep
some single episodes half of shift yeah
exactly you know like half a shift I
didn't realize how important that was
like when we were at the other Studio
like uh the length of the podcast really
is what matters like 40 Minute Podcast
but that's the guess that's all they had
like right I'm not even through an hour
of school yet oh okay I get it I get it
so we're trying to pass the time for you
guys so the one of the first winners
Benjamin greenstead thank you very much
second winner is Priscilla pigs like
your name yo I got the OG episodes I
love the OG episode full especially when
you talk about all the Paranormal [__]
because that shit's real full hahaha
I love it Priscilla pigs I just loved it
Priscilla pigs with a z and Benjamin
greenstead that's how we're starting
this off you guys are the winners of the
posters we will yeah we're gonna DM you
on Instagram since we have your
Instagram names
you know we did it right this time and
we'll shoot you a
um a message and get your address and
send it right out sorry I feel like I
started off super slow and
well professionally you're getting
business out of the way speaking and
[__]
um besides that right now you guys on
this episode we're gonna give away we
have seven items well currently we got
our first ever we'll keep it going
through this episode first ever fifty
percent flash sounds
there we go we're doing a 50 off sale
guys we made a bunch of merch uh a while
back and me and Marty decided like you
know what if we're gonna do it we need
to put our tags in we need to get it
folded and I mean we have it folded and
bagged and tagged but we want to step it
up a little more so we are going to
start something completely new we don't
have that much merch left so we're like
you know what 50 off we're not gonna
we're actually losing a dollar fifty on
each shirt but
who cares let's get them out there get
him out there it's super cool and people
are wearing it has our it's weird seeing
us on a shirt so thank you guys for
supporting that so right now we're going
to do a giveaway in this episode so if
you want to win one two three four five
six shirts of Hoodie shorts I think a
bean and a sticker pack almost 10 items
I believe don't quote me on that it's
about eight to ten items if you want to
win that all you got to do right now
drop a comment on the video you're
watching and leave your Instagram name
that's it because we're not gonna be
able to contact you on YouTube drop a
comment right now I don't care if you're
in the live chat not in the live chat
though drop it in the comments drop it
in the comment section just a comment
and your Instagram name that's all you
got to do I don't care if it's a thumbs
up and your Instagram name that's cool
we will pick a winner next week and that
it's like what 300 something bucks it's
like a 350 gift pack so thank you guys
so much leave a comment on this video
drop your Instagram handle in the
comments of this video and we will pick
a winner next next week
good job good chat man that was rough
crack that pig luck would you call it
Pig leg
like what are you talking about her name
is Priscilla pigs Pig leg all right guys
uh let's get started Marty has a bunch
of random things that he looked up let's
start off with that let's get like three
minutes in then we'll start smoking cool
yeah I just noticed as I was kind of
like going through
first of all when you get up in the
morning is there like a series of
websites that you just check every day
never in life really oh
I always kind of do it the same oh no no
like socials to make sure everything's
good and I'm not deleted my dad used to
read the newspaper in the morning yeah
it's because you're a human being yeah
but I do that with Worldstar and like
Vlad TV and Reddit and on Twitter I
don't know how to use Reddit
Vlad TV I don't really watch
world star turned into ads yeah dude
it's almost unwashable it's unwatchable
and then and that's it
I don't look at stuff so before you get
into this I don't know who 90 of the
humans are I don't know a lot of
celebrities because I just don't give a
[__]
and with court cases I don't know my my
news comes from memes yeah
what do they mean by that what does that
mean
huh and then two days later I see a news
report yeah oh that was not a joke
that's real like oh I didn't know he was
running for president it's like [__] it
was six months in yeah yeah I remember I
saw some memes I'm like is this real I
thought it was a joke so I don't pay
attention like it's sad the level that I
don't give a that's the watch I'm about
to get
top left oh sure
it just popped up right there
the exact dude
get out of here I just popped Worldstar
you really go hard with these ads you
really go hard why would you advertise
that of all things anyway want to start
a podcast add
okay so before we start no I don't check
anything at all
[Music]
that's it I usually come down the stairs
and go oh man I left all that out [__]
that's really my morning
okay well I noticed there was just about
there's a bunch of like legal cases
going on right now with famous people
that are kind of relevant to our world
shooting different kind of varieties now
keep in mind I don't know [__] about
this [__] either so we're gonna need you
guys to fill in the blanks and
somebody's talking in the comments help
us out also I I if you're gonna eat mad
at me remember I could care less about
what the [__] you have to say unless
it's positive it's positive or it's nice
or it's criticism but like actual
quizzes and not hateful [__] or biased
opinions I'll listen to you I'll even
talk to you but once I feel like oh this
guy is a brick wall I can I don't care
anymore you know what's you know what
really bugs me sorry for getting into
this there's been like four fans I've
gotten into it in the past week or two
that have been fans for five years
like I gotten into it like yo Bro you've
been here for a while you understand who
I am if you think I give a [__] about
what you got to say right now you can go
eat a dick the fact that you tell me
what I need to do tells me everything I
need to know about you you're the guy
that's like yo you can't park here no I
don't live here but it says no apartment
shut the [__] up and get out of my face
sorry people are just bugging the [__]
out of me lately but anyway I've blocked
like three [__] half a decade fans
past month like on some random [__] or
yeah DM me some [__] about like I'm
[__] up like first off
I don't know who you are I know your
name online we talk I know your [__]
screen name I don't know what you look
like which it doesn't matter just
if you follow me that long you should
know
I don't give a [__]
I could care less because I I don't do
[__] in heinously I'm never trying to
[__] somebody over so if you think I'm
doing some bad [__] like you need to
revive yourself not jump to conclusions
and get all the facts but also it's my
life so why the [__] would you know
those things
this little [__] dude like it's been
really bugging me yeah like it takes me
everything to go
I'll leave him alone and they say some
more she'll go I'm gonna I'm gonna let
you have it and I'm gonna block you have
fun watching from somebody else's page
because it's not gonna be on yours
anymore and it bugs me dude he's like
man you're a fan I feel bad now every
time they think about you a fan of that
guy that guy's a dick like that's sad I
want that at all no it's sad it's like
old friends and [__] no friends with no
more is it like you get the Vibes like
all those things like kind of just
tweaking right now like maybe something
I got a couple where people were like
just on a manic episode or some [__]
where I'm like yo something's up talk to
me another day and I've had a 90 of
people always come back I'm sorry bro
I'm going through some [__] like going
through some [__] you need to chill out
what the [__] could I do to you yeah
like oh sorry I was just you know me and
my girlfriend I'm like that's why I
called you to speak like bro what the
[__] are you talking about you're insane
crazy [__] dude
um
anyway the fact that you sit there and
really message back and try to figure it
out that was like oh important always
always dude because like are you just
saw some crazy nonsense or is there
actually because that like we're open to
like yeah we very well may be [__] up
I know I am like [__] if I'm [__] up
call me on some [__] I'm open to that
yeah but I'm trying to fix it yeah
exactly
but if you're just trying to like get in
my [__] head like or just say some
you're just I just think a lot of people
are uh
sad with themselves and they don't know
that yet so they're like just pissed
so they're like yo you're doing [__] I
would like to do I'm just gonna project
some [__] out to see if I can get
you to [__] bite on it and then now I
did something with my day yeah that's uh
it's it's I always feel bad for people
that do that [__] online because could
you imagine you're a parent like yo
that's my kid
[__] my kid's a loser that's sad dude I
would be so disappointed
[Music]
yeah for damn sure I mean
get to find out weird [__] about your
kids through the internet exactly sorry
before we start on this let's let's just
bust these out we may or may not have
straight lamb legs legs I don't know if
you can get close in that one these sir
are quarters and look it you know people
like you're overweight you're five nine
but you're 200 pounds like bro I'm a
bodybuilder you're gonna call me
overweight
everything's different these are both
seven grams one's long and skinny one's
fat and short what I'm trying to say is
don't be discriminating [__]
they're both seven grams those are some
of the biggest trays I've seen they're
both the same weight pillars those could
support weight those are those could
support buildings yeah exactly
I don't know if this is in your shot
does it look cool bam
all right so Marty bigger than my
[__] fingers for sure
oh yeah that's yours sir good looking
torch over here yes so what we're gonna
have to do we're gonna light these
together oh God because I actually
doubled up a little bit on your paper
okay so you didn't burn through it too
quick at the beginning okay oh I double
wrapped the front just I didn't want to
cut it off I was like you know what
Marty Burns fast let me let me show them
how to do this so this you're gonna like
these different okay okay I've been
actually paying attention to how I late
[__] lately good do you have a lighter
yeah
ready
is everyone at home we do the same exact
process that this one's a [__]
monster so if you let it wrong
it's gonna run ready walk with me
just the tip and yours didn't close it
was so fat that's like that's why it's
not closed you're always going to burn
different like this you always want to
put the flame out and let it go in when
you do it too much it burns odd and look
at twist
then right when it gets the whole
surface
blow it off
a little twist action again
then
and then you can see just no paper just
weed right
once you blow all that excess paper up
in there
this thing is Beast bro it's a beast
cbx tropical heat and something
uh biscotti rods or some [__]
I've been paying attention to how I
light my Jays though now it's a much
better experience careful right there
you see that black ring you got going
too close already you're doing this you
always want to go up
because you go sideways it's
unpredictable look
it's like a science bro it really is a
science I've ruined so many joints and
been so disappointed myself that I've
just got this ready
now let's go here
Like Larry Lawton cigar style like this
out in front and you put your joint into
it
because if not you're going to catch
underneath randomly
all right no more lighting
see how your side's a little too burnt
go like this
and then
just on the part that's too burnt
so you have some some torch you see how
the black is kind of torched on your
paper it's kind of yeah you lit it a
little too much but it's still looking
good now your joint is ready to go yep
don't puff it too hard and twist and do
the do the thing one more time on that
paper that's burning I can see it's
going to run so I run over here and just
if people are in the car it's like what
am I what am I listening to [__]
instructional tutorial
instead of the comments we'll go J's
with Yolo's like shooting around with
the All-Pro NBA [__] shooting coach
there's a lot of different variables
dude
there we go
I've never used to use
who broke the seal on Marty On The Go
episode
oh no no it's OG's episode
it was OG's episode now Marty costs it's
crazy
yeah yours I rolled longer so it's not
going to be as tight or not as tight
it's not going to be as like rock hard
right there
now you guys want to puff
twist
let that simmer all right let's talk
about court cases
yeah I love this Jesus Christ we need
eight I mean we need quarter joints
every episode this feels right this does
feel right I like this is what we do
this is our thing yeah how are cameras
to pick from you want to hit it slower
you have the lugs of a monster the
second you pulled
vacuum vacuum I can see him not bad just
you have some strong lungs get those
cold air lungs all right let's get into
these court cases so did you grow up
listening to Lil Boosie no
who was it that was just in here to tell
that he was their favorite I don't
remember I love I think he's awesome but
I did not grow up listening to his
southern music I didn't so much either
he kind of came into my awareness like
i-n-d-e-p-e all that hard oh okay wipe
me down I bumped that song a lot in my
in my car I like that song but he's
obviously he's one of the top rappers
that's crossed over on [__] social
media and like still relevant and [__]
he did the 50 set route was hilarious
he's just a hilarious person so you're
like yeah I kind of hear what else you
got to say that's a good point I will
say I never seen nobody talk to Lil
Boosie like Mike like Mike Tyson did
yeah yeah that was uncomfortable it was
very uncomfortable
if I was a little [__] like yo
I'm just gonna let this [__]
talk at me I didn't try to get punched
by this [__] thing or have problems
with this guy
it's not my Tyson just a fighter it's
like you are an Affiliated 50 year old
man with fools that love you Sarah
they'll kill for your ass across earth
across earth it's not just him it's
that's true the things that come with
you
and I mean not to mention Tyson just
disarmed a guy with his hands like at
the coffee shop
with a stare he made the guy put his gun
down
Mike Tyson did nothing but look at him
I can't remember if we talked about that
or not we did we didn't need to react to
that video I don't want to break that
down we do we got to
here hit this
damn switch joints are these you're
going you're going way too hard I know
your joint's gonna be gone in less than
four minutes all right I should have
rolled you a [__] shorter fat one I
knew I should have gave you that one
this is tropical heat from CVX that's
some runs and tropical heat
oh yeah yeah you're just you're just
ripping it because you're doing it to
that one too this is you yeah one mode
you're right you got one mode it's okay
not bad thing not a bad thing I need you
on my team if we have a competition so I
know that okay all right I'm gonna be
good for that he would be very good for
that all right Little Boosie what's
wrong with him so apparently the FBI
just took him down based off his IG
footage for what for having a gun
it's a gun he's in the South who gives a
[__]
there's a pellet gun but I'm saying why
I wanted to bring it up is because what
I mean literally they're sitting around
watching his life and then raided him
afterwards of course they are you know
it's a really good right I'm a cop
everybody let's do this I'm a cop I
really want to catch a little Boosie I
can't get any of his homies I can't get
into his house how am I gonna get in
there you know what let me watch this
guy's alive he's on the line every day
done
the internet is literally
evidence
stop doing [__] that you're not supposed
to do on there
but anyway the headline today because
the headline like yesterday was he went
down all this [__] but now it's granted
Bond and gun case documents reveal so is
that why he was selling his cullinan the
other day I saw a little boozy post a
video cash right now 2 40 like 240 for
the white Cullen and that [__]
is worth 340. on Instagram or some [__]
yeah it's like 340 a black badge that
she's like 490.
you are losing 100K on your brand new
colony
something's going on I didn't know he
was going to I know he's in trouble
[__] up man
it's Lil Boosie's awesome he's getting
he's gonna come back to this uh fade
higher than ever
he's gonna grow more hair get taller his
estate is going to get bigger his house
is going to get cleaner all that [__]
all right all the good things are gonna
happen
I love to get him on here too he's not
nearly as requested as he should be
that'd be a hell of an interview he gets
high as [__] he talks like my neighbor
growing up man I told you my neighbor Mr
Edwards from Mississippi well huh the
way he talks he's got that that's how my
neighbor talked but Steph he was
coach from waterboy I couldn't
understand anything you're going to hog
in that time oh I'm going to Oregon hey
now Thomas that's what you said okay yes
Mr Edwards I'm going to Oregon
I don't think I've ever actually met
anybody like that in real life I love my
um I used to sell weed real quick I used
to sell weed to this dude uh
yeah I won't say his name I don't know
if he cares I don't know if he knows or
wants that out so we do this dude
he's like
real real small dude real short dude
he's got like the weirdest blue like
your your Bill's hat blue eyes and he's
a black dude
light skin black dude his mom's German
his dad's black when I met him I go your
eyes look like a [__] water Oasis
stop staring at him you're gonna get me
pregnant [__] Jesus Christ but I
looked at him and go what
that color blue on the screen
I was like what the [__] yeah yeah your
watch okay it blew my mind I'm like you
like a National Geographic cover
anyway how much weed do you want so the
story I told on story time where I was
delivering sacks on my first days of
delivering pizza and my car wouldn't
start and this old man came down and
helped me that's who this is that's my
friend's dad okay
he's from the cell he's from
I believe Alabama or Georgia
his name was Jim he passed away his name
was Jim and he was about 70 years old
and he worked for GM for 35 years did
the paint
he knows everything about [__] pay
that you could possibly think of when I
got my Monte Carlo and I pulled up he
his face lit up so fat
and he looked at me yo young man youngin
he always just call me youngin he used
to call Rosie darling hey sweetie
darling and he'd walk in his old little
Shuffle here do he's an old black dude
from his out and he was like hip
like in the 70s he'd be doing this [__]
oh okay [__] that's the kind of
fool he was like he'd be doing this a
lot
swagging around it's hard very hard he
had two girlfriends one was in Oakland
one was in Frisco he was the coolest old
man he drove a Cruella DeVille Cadillac
not balling old man like a dope old man
and then uh I would trade him five grams
and he would buff and wax my car
one time he did it and I facetimed
somebody from it and they didn't realize
I was in a reflection until I backed up
oh [__] I posted on Instagram I went hey
what's up guys how you doing then I
backed up like that's my car
shining like I could it looked fake like
a GTA render anyway Jim was from the
south and he talked like that man he had
a sick ass accent
so yeah I only know a couple of that old
school old school [__] you know what
it's crazy they're both over 70 year old
dudes from the south I knew him very I
grew up in a very odd spot a town full
of Mexicans that grew up the only black
family in this in the ghetto all the
wrestling Mexicans and the only black
family in the whole [__] nurse said
right there Mr Edwards and everybody
when my mom saved that kid from choking
to death that's that was the neighbor
hmm crazy [__] bro
um I remember they named one of their
grandsons Beechnut
remember the group Peach nut beat nuts
oh beating up beatnuts okay his name was
Beechnut his real first name Beechnut
and I go Beach Nut
that's not his name and he was older
than me and uh Mr Edwards wife sold
candy through the whole neighborhood
so I would go in there she was the
scariest woman ever and she was so mean
but every time she re-up on Candy she
like hey what's up guys I'm like oh
you got some candy we'd walk in I
remember being a kid with change
I'd walk into the living room hmm but
she'd have two shelves there's hella
Chiclets there's gum there's single sour
strips you know what I mean there's
Warheads she took them out the pack and
sold them individually she was hustling
her ass off every candy you can think of
I'd walk in
and they're all on shells and be
standing there come on hurry up she was
mean old lady dude from the south she
was not nice to us she wasn't nice to
anybody the candy lady is
stereotypically nice yes Mr Edwards was
nice you know I don't want to say that
because they're Grand he's like the only
time of my grandma like yo I'm just
saying your grandma's very very not
friendly you don't have an opinion I can
have an opinions I think she was cool
she was a very cool lady Mr Edward's
wife she's got to be cool
um but yeah Beechnut he was like four
years older than me and I remember those
fools you do wheelies I'm like damn
these older kids are so sick but yeah I
grew up um I grew up with those kids my
whole life and then on the other side of
me were the Mexican kids and he was in a
karate and he was three years older than
me and his whole family was outside he
was doing some practicing and they're
like yo practice with him like
oh yeah yeah
I was kicking me in the face have you
talked to you about that he [__]
roundhoused me in my cheek swelled up I
started crying the whole family laughed
at me as I ran into my house how old
were you four oh was he even at school
yet the kid was in like second grade he
rounds kicked me in my [__] face
Marty I remember seeing him turn I went
why is he turning and I can't hit the
ground I started [__] just crying my
whole face right here had a bruise I
told my grandma she came next door and
yelled at them for letting their son
kick me and he meant to do it yeah they
were sparring he's a Karate Kid they
just went by yeah [__] kick that kid
he kicked me in the face and I remember
when it hit and I'm like yo that hurts
so bad
right here he hit me right in my [__]
cheekbone I remember I hit the ground
like I just started bawling I held my
face I looked up and the dad with the
mustache and some like the big ass
cowboy hat was laughing his ass off the
mom and the ground everyone was laughing
I was like what the [__]
we're in the ghetto the doors are six
feet apart from the next house I just
[__] sprinted in told my grandma and
then she yelled at him I never [__]
chill with that kid again
did he kick me in the face it was nuts I
remember seeing him turn around like
what
a lot of kids get kicked roundhouse
kicked to the face in their life also
what a [__] badass kid yeah he
[__] cool I mean do you just
roundhouse you're a [__] child that
was technical amazing it was so like now
they're looking out like wow but also
you know we'll bring it up on 6th Street
my Grandma's driveway the grass that
touches that's where I got kicked in my
[__] face
four feet from my [__] house it fell
into your living room
uh I don't know why we got this topic
damn oh Jim all black old black man I
was like you all know South man older
dudes born in like the 40s and 50s from
the south white black max I don't give a
[__] I have a different tone
[Music]
Mr Edwards had a crazier
and then Jim had the [__] like
Smooth almost like [__] like red and
Shawshank
no no
you know the [__] walk down the
street like this and [__] in the 70s all
smooth that's how that's how he talked
okay like some of the slang he would say
like what the [__] is that mean leaning
towards like James Brown yes and always
said cats uh-huh not people oh this cat
over here there's a young cat down here
[__] Jim was cool as hell I was
getting dressed putting my [__] pants
on
for the damn no the Denver Cannabis Cup
I think in 20s no
a cup out of state
I was putting my pants on get ready for
the cup and then someone called me like
yo Jim Pastor went like
I remember oh chin was cool man really
cool guy always owed me money he never
once I I fronted him in eighth once and
he let it ride he let it ride he'd come
up like yo he's that money I owe you
thank you
from me come on youngin from me another
bag yeah bag from your little bag I'm
like I'll get paid you know next week
gotcha Jim no worries
that [__] lasted three and a half years
he never once like totaled it out and he
did it
one time I got irritated with him I
remember he had like a revolving line of
credit that was like or I got irritated
with him once and then he like hey don't
get mad at me I was like come on Jim
bro what are you doing here he's wanting
me in front of like an ounce of my gym
I already [__] you haven't paid me back
for the and I was like nah man can't do
it he's like you're not gonna do it he
got kind of irritated I'm like no I'm
not
it was weird because I always did
everything for everybody irritated off
not getting confronted yeah I I he's a
old man he sometimes bring his old ass
homies too
they were old as [__] same [__] dudes
old as [__] old man with the afro but
all bald in the middle
but a big afro puff on this like oh he
his old man his homies were dope his
homie about a 10 sack and we're like
yeah everybody intense that did people
not do that was the 10 sack now my hands
like that it's about 20s dubs I'll sell
you double damn making eight dollars a
dub how much is it 1.3
yeah
what happened what happened court cases
let's get back let's get back I'm sorry
guys
same age same scenario my neighbor at my
grandma's house
we got into a fight for some reason she
Point Blank I'll never forget it soccer
kicked me cleaning the balls how old
were you probably about four oh you're a
kid okay maybe he's up upwards of six
Maybe
just straight collapse to the ground I
think we've we're never friends again
after that and we were like I could have
been but yeah that [__] sticks with you
I took a lacrosse ball clean to the
balls uh Point Blank I think I might
have told you about that I stepped in on
a lacrosse practice one time
after basketball practice that's to play
lacrosse though I'm just thinking about
trying out I was gonna try out for
lacrosse oh okay so you were part of the
activity I thought you meant like I was
walking down to a practice no I did
while they were practicing with them oh
well look that's what I thought after I
stayed after basketball gosh we're in my
[__] basketball jersey
with like shoulder pads under it that
was the only you know it was the
lacrosse team in high school and I
started playing defense like basketball
I'm like literally guarding this dude
with the stick out like you guard
somebody in basketball and he just point
blank shot to the net clean ball shot
dropped me to the ground same [__] only
two times ever in life
uh it was horrible I thought I was in
real trouble that was it I'd put the
lacrosse stick down forever after that
it was that Rocco was five and we asked
him what kind of party he wanted we have
a picture he wanted a mustache party
where everyone wears fake mustaches that
was his theme and he walked around with
fake mustaches different ones every
couple minutes
and then we were water ballooning
got this water balloon and I was hitting
Rio Rocco Memphis my other cousin
Rocco comes up to the porch like this
five years old probably six Maybe
and I throw the water balloon at him
kind of hard I wanted to pop
I don't know what happened I don't know
I have a very good arm I hit rock with
the [__] balls so hard and the water
balloon didn't pop at all I heard that
impact on this water balloon that hit
him and he just dropped and he started
crying and I picked him up and I was
like oh my God I'm so [__] sorry and
I just remember like trying to look at
him like
all right I swear it doesn't hurt it
does it doesn't
it's like no please because I was like
dude how do I stop this I can't [__]
stop this I did it to you [__] oh dude
so that's the time that's a ball shot I
know we're in on no topic yeah that's
what you just talked about that you do
feel like the biggest piece of [__] when
you hurt a kid I did that at April's uh
April's like Christmas family party they
had a game of dodgeball going
I just point blank just [__] Dome
this little kid and that full force same
[__] he dropped I didn't even really I
didn't mean it but yeah you feel [__]
awful not to mention the other day at
the mall first ever dad real dad blunder
like this in my career you
put I mean on my shoulders
walking through the parking lot boom you
hit her yes
on the concrete there was a little
overhang thing she had a hat on thank
God so oh my God I was just thinking
about her
10 million times have I dipped down well
I had a kid on my shoulders
one time I'm not thinking about it
[__] crack your Dome piece almost oh
a little enemy must have been so sad
that you did that to her yeah yeah she
probably looked you like how can I trust
you exactly
she's not a toddler she's like I'll
remember this oh that one's in there
forever God remember when you just
didn't care damn
okay that sucks
um yeah hurting kids is that what topic
we're on the I don't I don't hear I
don't carry babies well this episode's
everywhere I don't I hold babies I
haven't held John's baby really I don't
hold baby so like five months
because they they do that weird
Arch thing where they just go [__]
flat yeah and if you're holding them
they will like start to slip out
I'll hold a baby if I'm on a couch yeah
surrounded by pillows and I'm sitting or
sit back I don't trust I trust myself
but I'm I'm traumatized I [__] I told
the story I [__] dropped a baby on
his head
I tried to Baby on his head off two
steps damn top of the [__] babies
I spiked it dude dribbled I dribbled it
it was [__] horrible you know babies
are all head weight yeah all I heard was
ah how old were you [__] four or five
oh that's that's all right then
and then I met the kid when he was 21.
he doesn't tell me he was I'll sell his
dad some weed
damn you got a [__] story on you you
dropped a kid on his head and you saw
this Dad weed is in the dark two years
later
[Laughter]
so I gotta I used to live right one time
I don't know how my mom pulled it off we
had a house
the cross street from the college my mom
was going to school and working I almost
crushing when I was like
five
right
and across the street
was a lady from the UK and I have never
heard nobody from the UK like that
except I used to watch absolutely
fabulous the show from the UK it's one
of my favorite shows they all sound like
it because they're from the UK I never
met anybody in person that had an accent
and it just blew my mind
spoken I'm like oh my God you sound like
Alfred from Batman you know I'm a kid
and uh
she was so mean she was so mean
oh
anyways you're my neighbor
and uh she was like 70 right and she has
a son her son's my exact mom's age
right her son
I'm four or five I'm going over their
house I know that house because it's
modeled like ours we're across the
street my mom and the mean you late UK
lady clicked
okay fast [__] homies chilled all day
every day anytime they could and she
would always scold the [__] out of me if
I didn't listen to my mom she was that
lady
like
[__] you're not my [__] mom who are
you trying to discipline right now she
was that [__]
and uh
ah we got into a bunch of [__] me and
her were [__] butt heads I'd be like
hey you know my mom don't talk to me
like that
and one time I hit in a [__] drawer
to get away from her ass once because
she was coming in to make sure I was
asleep and I was in the hallway because
I want to be in my bed and I jumped into
a [__] drawer and then she opened it
and she's like go to sleep and I can
think like Mom where the [__] are you
why are you letting this [__] [__]
do this to me
I don't like her she loved my sister
though which is crazy my sister was
always so mean I think she was just
scared to be mean to her my sister was
scared to be mean to the lady says she's
like you you act right I was always
challenging this whole like who the [__]
are you that's all I kept thinking like
David Bowie or the [__] man from
snatch the guy that speaks people to
pigs that's what she looked like to me
um
back then I was a child
so one day we're over there and I'm just
like [__] hate this lady
maybe we should believe that one
and I'm like holding the baby and I tell
my mom eight times before she hands me I
don't wanna hold the baby don't want to
hold the baby don't hold the baby I
don't want to hold the baby I told like
14 [__] times I mean I don't I don't
like it it scares me what if I drop him
I'm standing there these two full-grown
adults will the [__] the UK [__] is
over 60. my mom is a 30 year old woman
I was five well I was like 24. it
doesn't matter
I'm holding the baby like this
like [__] I'm waiting for them to come
back they go to get their coffee and
they'll catch in or something I'm
holding the baby like this standing
two steps living room sliding glass door
and I'm like okay
all right and the baby just goes and
does the arch you know with arms and
legs out yeah and I'm like
I'm a kid and I go like this and I try
to squeeze tighter but the tighter I
squeeze the more I'm going under it
because it's arching how much kid I
don't I'm just trying to react yeah and
I'm like this no no and the [__] baby
dies backwards
and as it's falling I try to go again
like this I'm a kid there's no way I'm
gonna stop I just wanted to stop it from
Juan's head and the [__] baby just
goes like this
remembering Toy Story when Buzz tries to
fly and then realize like
I imagine the baby just
you are a toy you can't fly that's how I
felt
and uh and then Randy Newman and then
the baby hit his head
do its [__] face
screaming death screaming when babies do
the death screen when they turn red and
they don't Breathe It Takes a second
then they do it
the ground I go down to grab him like oh
my God and then they're walking in and I
just start freaking the [__] out I told
you not to [__] give me I was like I
told you I'm screaming crying at the top
of my lungs screaming too because I'm
like I just killed the [__] baby oh
my God I heard it
and then they look at me like I'm the
dumbest [__] person on Earth and I'm
looking at them like how many times did
I ask you not to give me why did they
force this baby there's a couch right
there could have just put the baby on
the couch
they were like no you'll be fine that's
exactly what happened oh you got it it's
a baby it's baby you watch the baby my
[__]
um
except in Toy Story the arm came out
baby then arm didn't come out and yeah
and uh I think about that as I will go
daily that's how I felt
and then um
I scream and cried and I never held a
baby again I didn't even hold Rocco to
like six months damn I was so scared
no he was like four months and we think
we took a picture
with him and he's little and I was like
that you can see it on my face I'll find
it there's a picture of me holding Rocco
like a newborn and I'm like that
you can see how scared I am on my
[__] face holding this baby in rocco
I just sit there as a [__] child
I mean babies are so [__] fortnite is
here yeah exactly God I hate building
babies dude
um
that's what happened
fast forward
doing mushrooms my homies I got this
older dude Right This Guy's in his 40s
and I'm 19.
seldom
[__] I'm smoking weed with them and
we're selling we I sold him some weed
and my homies are like yo
I'm gonna get him attack it wasn't over
so I wouldn't get him a ride can you
guys take him home like don't trip man
I'll take him home it's Merced so small
mile away I got it like yeah I'll take
you home and I'm like oh nice you know
it's the first time ever meeting you
know I got you but it was kind of odd I
was like I've never met this person it's
your friend I'll drive my phone it's
fine he was cool so we're talking
driving hitting the streets
Grand Theft Auto camera you imagine us
above the you know going through above
our [__] just talking yeah do this oh
you're a Giants fan yeah I'm actually
from from York man okay I could tell I
can tell you with your accent he's from
New York I'm like yeah one of the only
guys with an accent Merced besides his
mom from the UK or Mr Edwards from the
south there's nobody with accents except
Spanish
um and uh
we're hitting streets I'm like oh I used
to live around here he goes oh no no
[__] yeah and we're turning
and I hit the street and I go I actually
used to live on this street he goes no
[__]
like yeah that's crazy and I drive and
as we're pulling up
and it's a cul-de-sac so we're like two
houses in his house is on the back left
my house he's on the back right and I
was about to go there was this [__] ass
old [__] lady from the UK and I hated
her I was about to [__] speak those
words to him like
and he goes this house and I go
this is your house
I pull up and it's her house I go this
is your house
what's your mom's name and he says it
and I go
and I say or say your name back that's
your mom
I go wait
did I drop your son on his head and go
did anybody's like wayo would you just
say I go
do you have a son I was like he should
be about this old he goes this is
exactly how old he is go wait
do you know Emily he goes
Emily yes and pepper like he's like I'm
Thomas
there's Thomas like Emily's little son
he goes shut the [__] up you help me
build my [__]
my [__] Power Ranger put them all
together on Christmas day there's a
picture of it there's a random white
dude look at Ned Flanders like that was
you because you're the little [__]
kid this is coming to the book of the
pool your little your sister's shirt I'm
like you know
what what man I'm like so I dropped your
kid on his head I'm the one he's like
you're the kid that oh my God maybe
that's why he's a [__] [__] that's
what he said that's all he said maybe
that's why he's a [__] [__] and I
know this man still he's coming he'll be
at my wedding I love this voice I've
kept up with him since I was 19 years
old
you want to go back to Mercedes stop by
and say what up to him
that's his mom
the UK lady
that was his son that I dropped on his
head and then one day
um he said because I gave him some
stickers when I first started doing dope
Zola and he said he came home he's like
why do you have the sticker on your
fridge
he goes it's my friend he goes no no
where did you get this sticker dad he
goes That's My Friend Thomas he goes
how do you what do you where'd you get
the sticker
and he watched all my [__]
and then didn't realize his dad that he
thinks is a whack-ass older man it's
like I get high with your guy of your
favorite YouTuber probably every week
twice a week three times a week like all
the weed I've been sneaking around you
I'm buying it from him
honestly he came on like Dad why'd you
have the sticker like you think you're
tight like he's like it was so fun
together though that something like that
didn't happen nah didn't happen I think
he grew out of it because he was like my
son's such an [__] he would always
say he said he's I just wish he was
nicer to me because my homie he's so
cool he's so nice he's just he's that
you ever seen a Pineapple Express
remember the guys that come up he's like
you want to buy you got any percocets
why tell me to buy Percocets man
he's those guys to his son like well you
know what I'm just gonna hang out you
guys want to do some stuff all right I
got some Jorts on you know I got some
new balances and like literally you know
your Dad's getting [__] ripped with
me at my house every other day it's just
it was a funny situation when I met his
kid he's like you really know me yeah
what's up man and in my head I was like
you're the one that's kind of mean here
Dad you should be nice to your dad and
in reality I went hey I dropped you on
your [__] head and I explained it to
him he goes really that's that's cool
I'm like
some kind of is an [__] suspected a
bigger reaction but really I gave him
the whole swingers oh okay cool I was
like you don't think that's insane
that you watch my [__] you're a big fan
and you have caused trauma to my life
for my whole life
and you didn't even know it was you I
think that was like very full circle
weird yeah I was like that's it you kind
of hard [__] but I've talked to him
since he's like he's so much better now
he's cool we hang out like he's my
friend now my good it reminds me of that
business story he told exactly exactly
dude the Big Jay oakerson one yeah
but oh you don't give a [__] that was
insane
anyway uh
that happened
stop why are we here it made me think of
my worst parenting moment ever
Ariana was probably
uh two so I'm a new parent struggling
super hard so I go into Wilson Farms
with Ariana what does that mean
it's like uh aren't you sir it's more of
like a
corner store it's like a chain Corner
Store Cool 7-Elevens but yeah exactly
just like a 7-Eleven Bakery
and I was refilling my [__] Green Dot
prepaid debit card
because we were probably in check
systems or some [__]
and like I'm arguing with the lady at
the counter over this like fee I was
having over the card and like I had to
call the bank and whatever [__] and I'm
like there's people behind me and Ariana
had never done anything like this before
as I'm doing that she [__] just
leaves
she [__] just leaves the way you said
it is like yo we're at the bar and she
got pissed off and just bounced
just please
she was
she was just like at my legs you know
like the whole time
and then next thing I know I'm arguing
with this lady just trying to figure out
without it and somebody walks in hey is
this somebody's kid
and it was the biggest piece of [__]
moment I've ever felt in my life lowest
point possibly
I didn't even realize she had [__]
dipped outside
and she was outside wandering around
have been for more than a few moments a
bit it too bad like but after that I
remember I was [__] I don't beat my
like the [__] out of myself up mentally
a lot that was definitely one of those
moments
like oh you got a really super you can
never ever let your guard down ever when
you got this kid no
never so yeah I was I mean it was a good
lesson learned though because I think
about that [__] all the time and I've
never until I just bumped Emmy's [__]
head the other day I haven't had an
incident
dude
I'm so on top of it when I have to have
kids around tube I remember once we'll
get onto the topic but I remember one
time
I was at The Grove apartments I was like
in 10th Grade Rocco was
eight months
and I watched Rocco a lot
and I remember we have you know those
glass side tables and you put the glass
down inside and it has the
yeah like the the groove where the glass
goes down but if you go from the bottom
you can take it out clean it
they're old they're heavy
I remember Rocco you know he's doing his
thing he's crawling I'm just chilling
and I always hear him he's a baby I'm
gonna make sure he's good
he's crawling around and I'm watching
them I think blow the movie blowing them
like I was watching it like what
it's been a couple seconds where's Rocco
and I look over
like so quiet and I looked down
and I'm like what's going on what is he
doing and his face is bright red crying
like tears but no noise
and he put his hand under the glass and
pushed it up and got one finger stuck oh
God one little finger was stuck in the
groove with all the weight of the glass
on it ugh he's trying to cry and it must
have been like [__] five seconds I
this was going on I didn't even notice
whenever I [__] lost my [__] like oh
my God this motherfucker's finger I was
just oh dude what did I do because when
it's on your watch like what the [__] is
wrong with me
he doesn't understand that that would
hurt him you know I mean I just felt
soap there's a couple instances in my
life where I was like until you get used
to watching a little kid I had never
really
had experience with a kid before that
oh yeah same same here same here man
we're lucky everybody knew what to do
she just knew what to do across the
board and I just kind of followed along
and learned you know by the third one
now I got it down
kids heads are getting bumped on the
[__] wall
um okay
very huge left
rant City yeah
that was one court case Okay whole
joints whole joint one court case can
you just talk about that yeah
what's what's next that thing was that
was like a whole experience [__]
burning down that joint all right
now another case I don't know anything
about it doesn't we got NBA star Zion
Williamson
plays for the Pelicans the Pelicans I
know right who's that name of all time
I'm sorry if that's your team where are
they from the New Orleans Pelicans
that's new that's a newer name
Washington football team is better than
the Pelicans
we don't do [__] but swallow stuff is
what your mascot is we only swallow [__]
whole famous for being a swallower
and nothing else
oh [__] I would have a sick ass Voodoo
[__] logo in New Orleans I've been
doing something better than the Pelicans
is it like a Pelicans a lot down there
apparently is that the bird of the state
yeah that's [__] stupid sorry Zion
Williams I don't know who that is I
don't follow basketball as much as I
used to he obviously he's a basketball
player for that team yeah continue so
apparently
there's this girl that was like
threatening him over a sex tape she had
like with him yeah like Pelicans you
better release this [__] I'm
getting ready to drop this kid release
him this is gonna work I don't
understand how what she was really going
for there's probably more to it but she
was like threatening to release this
tape over online
and then Twitter deleted her account
which I kind of let's go respect it it
makes it's another reason
Twitter's like the Spotify around here
they do [__] they do [__] that's like oh
it works what you guidelines say it
works sick
yeah so yeah I just wanted to get your
thoughts on that like my thoughts I'll
break it down for you right now
what's your name don't matter who gives
a [__] some dumb [__] allegedly Mariah
Mills
honestly I don't care if people get
upset over me saying that I don't care
if she gets upset that is the most
scandalous [__] I've ever heard in my
life
NBA I have sex tapes and me and Zion
Williams and he also has them on his
tracfone at NBA Pelicans at NBA trade
himself trap phone
when you don't sell drugs it's the wrong
word it's the wrong term yeah he's a
[__] basketball burner phone works
yeah second phone works other yeah
TracFone is stupid TracFone is just
shows me that I think that's why weed's
gone downhill that everybody thinks that
they [__] sell weed now and that's
why all the prices are [__] up because
everybody is trapping
that pisses me off more than the sex
tape sorry more than the threats the
proper usage of the Trap yeah like don't
just say that you're you're also putting
a whole bunch of other [__] on him by
saying that yes yeah the first thing I
thought of what do you mean is travel
what is this fool doing
people just don't understand terms
go ahead and uh trade him now he doesn't
deserve to be in New Orleans sex tape so
by [__] her on a sex tape according
to her he just no longer qualified to be
a pelican
okay so obviously he banged his girl
now she's mad at him
let me I'm gonna talk directly to the
camera real quick
this girl Moria Maria who [__] it you're
[__] tripping
that's it nothing more you're just a
girl that this guy banged and now you're
mad that that's all it is
so now he doesn't deserve to be a new
that's the craziest [__] I've ever heard
is she like an artist or or like like a
model if she's a model
if she just is pretty
she's tripping
this is she's an artist from there she
might be like yo this is our town this
Fool's tripping he did some weird [__]
to me that I can understand she's a porn
star [__] out of here oh
really she's got a hello Portland first
shift that comes up is playing
go to Instagram
I got to make sure because if she's from
New Orleans like as an artist
that's different different story I can
see that
who is it what does she do
she's a porn star for real that's it
that's interesting and Tupac's your
profile
the most disgruntled what is it
okay so this is how I feel that's insane
that's crazy that's a tweaker [__] right
like that's the weirdest threat isn't
that is that illegal black is that
blackmail
it sure feels like is that illegal
you're just trying to like get something
oh she's not trying to get well I mean
she is trying to get some because it's
one thing like for instance when you
know one of the like let's just say
let's say a stand-up comedian gets out
of this being a creep uh there might
have people calling comedy clubs saying
hey you got this [__] creep
performing at your Club that's different
one thing that's different but to just
be like I have a sex tape I'm gonna
release it if you don't release him is
crazy that is that is Ultimate
I'm gonna slash your tires because
you're not with me wow that's the
ultimate bitter [__] [__]
that's sad I mean I always feel bad for
p like then again let's talk about this
girl I feel bad for her if that's what
she's doing like putting her energy into
would that qualify you to go to get a
rest of those kind of the other question
but
um depending on what she's doing because
she's willing to do that she's willing
to pay some fools to go [__] shoot
this dude or something that's sad
he's just a basketball player he just
banged you that's all there's more
basketball players [__] go bang the
different one guarantee you right now if
you shut out five DMS four of them would
say yes
you know why because you're a girl just
DM them if you think it's different you
know what's better kid with a different
basketball player on the team or or who
cares
or who cares yeah like just that's crazy
Marty see this is why I stay off the
internet because now these people that
now they're gonna get mad at me because
I called her dumb
this dude on YouTube thinks he's even
talk [__] about me like Mitch talk [__]
about YouTube these are just reactions
to these uh headlines here folks you
just do pornography and you're trying to
get a guy basically it's saying like yo
I got this podcast Marty and if you
don't stop working with these people I'm
gonna drop this podcast like wait what
oh cause you're a porn star and it's sex
tape so it's work
so basically what you're saying is
you're trying to make money this could
be her trying to get money and if that's
the case
she's not that dumb because all it's
going to do is make people go
how much you want for that tape right
now that probably it has to be like the
layer that has to be what she's doing
because if that's the case you know what
[__] do your thing
okay all right do you think because
he probably was like yo girl let me get
you this and then he's like you know
what I don't like you that much she's
like oh I'm gonna get what you promised
me in one way or another and if that's
the case she's on some CB4 if you got
your own car and your own place then you
as a businesswoman if not use a hoe it's
a good movie
damn and like adjacent NBA news looks
like they gave John Ryan at 25 games
especially 25 cases budget here you go
this is another thing this is let's talk
about this kid
he's another one of these people that uh
would say trap phone
gotcha but never sold a sack in his life
why is he rolling around with a gun look
at that face go up look at his face and
his pose and you're gonna tell me that
man needs a gun
therefore needs some some homies around
them
that is
that is a flamboyant pose
that pose doesn't scream gun villain to
me that pose screams hmm girl that's
what that post says to me it could just
be a frame but that I hope it's just a
frame because that frame is not a hook
mustache he doesn't look menacing can
you find a different picture of him I'm
sorry I feel like I'm over here talking
[__] about this man's pose
but with the he's the gun guy
I just saw him post a video he had a oh
that was just a pose he had the uh I
thought it was like he was gonna speak
like one of my home one of my homies I
was ahead of I had a certain voice in
mind
oh that was just a pose
so wait he had this gun lighter so I
think he was like then trying to say
like it was just a writer he's got in
trouble many times already showing guns
correct this is my take on it if you're
an NBA player or a place where people
look up to you kids look up to you you
probably shouldn't be rolling around
with a gun in your videos it's a bad
look not saying you're not entitled to
it have that gun on you you're rich but
probably don't you know
what other kids that look up to You're
Gonna think like yo he's got guns and
he's a professional like that's not it's
not a bad thing and it's not the guns
that's bad it's the flan it's the
it's the showing off of gun culture
that's bad do you think the NBA has a
right
to tell you 100 just like you can't
write a jet ski as a football player on
the off season because you might break
your arm you can't be flashing guns on
your Instagram that's crazy
it's insane if you're doing some
tactical [__] looking like it's out of
at a gun range and you're practicing
different but doing this gun [__] waving
it around
fuels the
younger kid
when I was 17 I saw a picture of The
Jacka and he had this hat on and he had
one two three four five six like swish
hello swishers
and I was like
that's the hardest picture I ever see in
my life
and the next time I got a swisher I
bought more swishers I'm like yeah
that's just hard I stuck in my head and
I just got so much swishers
I was influenced by a picture because I
thought it was up what am I into weed
and [__] if you're into guns and [__]
a song My influencer but yeah [__] yeah
a lyric but you see I just did that I
just shot out into a crowd
music influences people so [__] hard
so fast
NWA look at the gang culture Spike after
all East Coast West Coast [__] spiked
murders
Led Zeppelin never had a had shootings
happening it's about what you're talking
about obviously Led Zeppelin's talking
about nerd [__] and Vikings and you know
stupid [__] I'm talking about like yo
don't push I mean the music isn't one
thing I I listen to crazy music all day
I know the difference between being
influenced by crazy music and just going
damn that's a wild story a lot of people
listen to gangster rap because it's a
storytelling
they'll listen to a story they've never
even heard of that's what people lost
prison movies and prison stories like yo
it's a wife and that's real wow that's
something I've never seen that's why
people like crazy rap
[Music]
it allows them to tap into a confidence
too like I think like you might not walk
around the super uber superhero
confident dude but then when you put on
that music you can like tap into that
see this office space yeah remember the
beginning when he's [__] rapping
hella hard and then this guy goes back
yeah it just gives people like I think
it lets people go something different
than what I'm used to but what I'm
saying is this guy how old is he
between right three four
23. pretty young yeah what was he
growing up we're up in Tick Tock Vine
Instagram YouTube that's where all he
sees is gun videos and SoundCloud
rappers are the biggest artists to him
and [__] of course guns and pills and
leans is going to be in the culture
because that's what the culture is so
this fool can't be doing that [__] if
you're an athlete back like an athlete
that's all but also do your thing just
don't put it on your Instagram full dude
Ray Lewis shot a [__] in a club
I ain't never seen him on Instagram live
with a pistol
it's a fair plan he murdered somebody
plus Goldberg shot himself in the foot
in a club
I didn't see him posting pictures of it
though yeah he tried to keep it under
wraps because that's what you're
supposed to do waving the gun shows me
that you have no felonies you've never
done [__] and a few cops came you're not
gonna do anything but go I'm an NBA
player
you can't act hard when you're not and I
feel like I'm I'm not trying to like
cause problems and smooth [__] but I
feel like that dude needs to shut the
[__] up go to the strip club [__] he was
doing they try to make him look like a
villain for spending all that money in
strip club bro if you think Tom Brady
hasn't thrown a million at a strip club
you're a [__] idiot so
just do your strip club [__] and have
fun do NBA player [__] don't be throwing
[__] gangster [__] have fun with your
life and don't
you know what's gonna happen and some
people how much money is that full worth
all right when I see him
I'll see if he's got that little gun on
him and that's what the [__] gonna
happen because you can't do that you
can't act like that when you're not like
that and I'm not saying he isn't sure he
might be a good ass fool I'm just saying
from the look of him right now I'm just
judging him other book of his cover he
looks like a nice dude looks like a nice
guy and I saw the video where he's
smiling and doing the gun it's kind of
like when girls do the uh
ah tongue [__] video it's like it's like
a default it's like done done or when
you see [__] fools show their homies
they just start doing this with their
hands up bro what are you doing why are
you pretending to shoot me like I don't
even hang out with you you just shoot
people
with you
that that culture is everywhere and I
see it a lot and it's sad it's like bro
do you really like shooting people why
you're gonna go in prison forever when
the iPhone [__] 45 comes out you're
gonna be in prison and what are we gonna
do forgot you
it's all these fools doing crazy [__] on
the internet with guns or if I'm getting
fights and shooting like bro you're
gonna be in prison with [__]
are gonna mop you
forever
that sucks just because you wanted to be
hard on Tick Tock you were in prison now
I think people don't think about and the
last final thought is I don't think he
shows like yo young people look up to
your ass this gun waving just made it
okay for [__] 30 000 kids to do gun
waving now
which is not good when you're an NBA
player if you're a gangster rapper fool
that's what you do they want you to
level up to a level of like be Kobe
everybody should just try to be Kobe
Bryant just try to be Kobe Bryant and be
the [__] man and shut the [__] up and
get paid 200 mil yeah shut the [__] up
and dunk the ball when you're getting
paid that much people don't
I don't feel like I have that much
sympathy for like no if you're getting
paid that much bro put up get a security
guard to wave his gun that's right
behind you have your security guard with
a [__] shotgun in there right there
dancing with the gun but not you like
you were worth too much money I would
expect somebody like that to have Obama
security right the level of like you
know low income but you shouldn't have
to have that security because you know
what you know who doesn't Kevin Durant
doesn't
Kevin Garnett doesn't
okay like they're they're don't hold
themselves like this yeah and they're
seven something they stand out literally
people know they're millionaires but I
guarantee you he's walking to a
restaurant with his wife by himself this
fool needs that security because fools
are going to try to test his ass my
April sucks and [__] Pavilions oh
that's right he's just walking around
with his kids at a grocery store by
himself exactly because he's just a
basketball player he's not
showing because if you know what it is
people don't realize that when they do
that gun [__] there's fools that are out
there going we'll see when I see you
because that's all they have in life
you're challenging their craziness thank
you and it's not a challenge to them but
they're insane and they're gonna take it
as that yeah exactly oh you think your
heart how much is he worth [__] this
floor that's what people do and that's
why they test rappers so hard but oh
that's what you're you're talking about
that in the story I just killed three
fools last week I might shoot you and
take a [__] but I want to see if you're
really hard it's like prison [__] like
yo we're gonna come test you as right
[__] now acting like that really got
to consider that [__] every day every
time you step out of the house anyway
it's a weird lifestyle because it's like
I don't know who is listening to my
music who likes it who doesn't like it
who feels a weird way who like anybody's
butt hurt about nothing everybody who
pass in these little towns now like this
[__] is different for sure especially
when you're really putting yourself out
there when you're putting yourself out
there and in a negative way yeah exactly
oh you better be on your [__] yeah you
have to be you know what I mean like
I guarantee you J Cole rides his bike
around jayco's one of the most famous
artists in the world he's riding his
bike chilling with his headphones on hmm
there's a reason he's not talking about
[__] pistols and saying that he's
hard and saying he'll shoot people
because people that shoot people go oh
do you um
I'ma shoot at you and see if you shoot
back and just because they can go home
and go I'm the one that popped that fool
it's just a little [__] a little
point for them to go on yo I popped him
because that's them that's that's their
life if it's not your life you'll stay
out of it you don't ever see
I have friends that roll around with
[__] weaponry
because that's the lifestyle that they
chose to like
project out when I go to a gas station I
see game bangers I don't have problems
with them
I don't have to go like when you're
looking at full it's never happened you
know why because I'm not looking to
attest to you like where are you from
fool oh I got a [__] gun like now I'm
like hey man actually I'm just High
sorry if I was staring like I was
spacing the [__] out I'm hot as [__]
sorry for my guys my bad
yeah
I have guns have you ever seen me
[__] dancing with him that's insane
and that's the reason why like I feel
like I'm at the grocery store food it's
fine
if a gangster comes up to me his gang's
friends are like fool you know what that
is
why are you testing this for he's like
funny he's just chilling not a gangster
it's just I don't know dude it's it's a
I've seen it I've had hella gamemaker as
a friend fans and sometimes I'm like oh
what's this for one
oh yeah that's right sick let's see
it's always like oh you're staring at me
because of what what am I doing oh
you're a fan [__] yeah good I thought
some [__] was gonna happen we really had
that moment
yeah you guys did shout out to wherever
that dude was yeah I was done I'm
walking in my car and [__] kind of
locked eyes it's like oh it looks like a
gang banger
going locked eyes back again again oh
[__] up third one's the bad one I love
your videos bro you
see that's the thing it's like we don't
put that out there
and if we did like
uh
milk 74. we brought him on the show
we could have problems right now
depending on the way we act and ask
about stupid [__] and the stupid [__] we
ask about and they're laughing about it
maybe we laugh about it and that gang
bangers like oh you're laughing about me
on the [__] internet now watch when I
see you yeah and it's like yo all we did
was an interview like no you didn't what
you did is you [__] push this little
beef [__] you wanted to talk about
it and now you have to [__] do a deal
with consequences you can't just be
honest the interviewer yeah you can't do
this very very true can't do that [__]
that's why people like you can ask about
this like nah yeah I was so proud of
that interview because we talked about
his life we didn't talk about nothing no
drama because why like
you guys could do that [__] so that's
that's the thing like you walk around
like oh what's up man I like your videos
I got gangbanger ass fools come up to me
all the [__] time and it's always
chill I'm always like what's up I mean
like once again like
it's just about how you hold yourself
this Fool's holding yourself weird
he could go through his whole life as a
Kobe being a [__] Nike dunker just
make money let's make your money because
right now he's not making his money I
got 25 game suspension
for not and like Gilbert Arena said like
when it happened to him he's like I lost
40 50 million through Nike just he lost
his Nike deal too yeah like come money
you would have earned that's just off
the table now
it's been so lucky to be the point oh oh
oh one percent of people that get to do
this in their life you got to like
respect it that's how I feel
yeah but like remember Johnny Manziel I
know this is off topic but Johnny
Manziel the quarterback carries from
they kept like oh he's drinking going to
strip club his party like bro he's a
[__] Rich athlete leave him alone and
then it got so big they were talking
about just like this but except this is
a gun thing it's just what do you guys
want to [__] about next is really what
it is how about you stop filming them
they're doing it every day you think
people aren't Matt Barnes said what do
you say every day I smoke about 40
blunts you call like eight girls all
over me getting high and getting drunk
and then you know we [__] go to
practice like
[Music]
just don't don't video me that's all
this [__] has to happen no phones inside
no phones inside and all these problems
go away but this Fool's on his live
which is crazy he's putting himself on
it which is the worst thing right just
you can't do that if someone catches you
doing [__] different that guy's a dick
for posting it yeah
yeah I mean like right now you're the
dick and for everyone in Memphis they're
like bro you're good we need you on the
team that you stop [__] up twice you
know it's the second time that really
did it like real fans are upset yeah why
do we pay this money for this this guy
he's good but he's not even playing now
there's so many players that and also
there's so many more people that would
love your spot you can't be doing [__]
like that
was a long rant but continue I have more
joints yeah Memphis pick up professor
[Music]
there we go all right now uh do you know
who tax down is no so tax stone is a
dude out of New York City
whose name is sick
look at these little James
okay
techstone yeah and he was like his mug
shot that's [__] up
bad mug shot
he was in on the ground floor of hip-hop
podcasting
so he had a podcast probably like maybe
2012 well attack season I really enjoyed
the [__] was like before drink Champs
came out
uh probably before Joe buns podcast came
out
definitely before a million dollars
worth of game like it was like audio
only even type of podcast but he was
just like a
[__] thank you Jesus Christ
just interesting personality but um he's
been in jail for the past couple years
for
this shootout with Troy Ave is a rapper
yeah so he had like an ongoing like he
had a shootout with the guy yeah did
anybody die in the Irving Plaza where
were you are you serious yeah he shot
out that nice ass place oh those people
are scarred
isn't that where you did the meet and
greet is that why I'm thinking of it
something just happened there wait you
talk about New York yeah Irving Plaza
sorry I was thinking the Irvine Spectrum
kids
I was thinking about your spot like they
shot out that nice asset right sorry the
Irving Plaza is where we did uh the meet
and greet New York yes it's a six-pop
they got a shootout there yeah they had
a they had a um
Feud going
oh okay okay so yeah did anybody die
yeah I think uh I think Troy ave's
bodyguard
but uh Touchstone was saying it was
self-defense and all this stuff but he
ended up getting 35 years
as of yesterday I believe oh
35 years is so long to like so he's
gonna die there how old is he
it's got to be oh he's 37. oh he's
barely oh he's not even old
but like he was a wild dude like if
you'd know his life story like
[Music]
yeah I feel like his show had so much
potential but also also the Sally guy
died oh of course it's really sad yeah
but 35 years and it could have been
self-defense I don't really know the ins
and outs of it but I was he's he still
has a Twitter so you could like still go
on as well if someone's shooting at you
and you shoot back I think it's pretty
safe to say that you're good
it's tough that's sad dude it reminds me
of like uh remember when shine went to
jail like
nah
like okay she talked with like puffy and
JLo and some dudes start trying to fight
puffy and he shoots off and hits
somebody else and you go to jail for 30
years
now shine
you know what first of all Sean was like
not a one hit wonder his first album
yeah I know who he is but uh not do you
know about him now no
mace is the pastor now right exactly
okay so this look I'm gonna get back to
where shine real quick but this is the
tweet from taxon that I was uh thinking
about how can you testify an open court
that you and your friend decided to beat
me up and then beat me up and I
protected myself and you claim
self-defense
no
no I don't think so I don't know about
that one
so but anyway just to kind of wrap this
Randomness up real quick so shine is
currently
so Sean went to prison for the puffy
case in controversially like puffy you
know is the one that probably shot him
and he took that before is what you're
saying God knows what happened or if
puffy was supposed to help him more than
he did or what did he pay for his
lawyers and [__] I don't know the ins
and outs shine talked about all this
[__] on drink Champs I think
uh because now
he's out well he's uh he's one of the
leaders of the House of Representatives
and Belize
so he got I don't know if he got
deported or if he went back to Belize
where he's originally from incredible he
got out but he's like a political leader
now you know trying to police like you
know a cool place for people around the
world to go to really yeah this is this
is him now when did he get out
so uh no way that's [__] awesome
I'm not sure he got out a long ass time
ago but so he didn't do 30 years
wow guys uh
my bad I don't know the story on this
man
okay he was acquitted to charges of
attempted murder oh attempted murder not
even murder 10 years in prison without
parole he served nine years in New York
prison ugh
because yeah bystander got shot that's
sad
um yo his album was so
he he was so on fire when that happened
he had this show with Barrington Levy he
was like kind of taking Biggie's place
because he was from Brooklyn he sounded
just like biggie
but uh apparently he was like from
Belize and I don't know but uh yeah
anyway sad situation with the tax Stone
If you ever
wanting to listen to some hip-hop [__]
that 35 years that's sad man that's
really sad
there's a lot of court cases
all right I got another one for you
let's do it and I had no little to
nothing about but as heavily in the
headlines
the uh you know anything about the ynw
Melly double murder trial I know nothing
about what's going on I know that he's
an artist and he has a song called
Murder on my mind and then he went to
prison for a murder trial and I'm like
yo bad timing bad timing for that song
to be popping
for him I mean that's yes that's a bad
bad timing I noticed today his attorney
had her own mug shots posted
old mug shots of his attorney
what'd you go to jail for though that
that's what I'm wondering man it could
have been anything
so what's the story on this guy he
killed two two friends he says
oh she was arrested for battery
uh damn yeah so he's he's on trial for
allegedly murdering his two friends his
own homies yeah
and they were grilling the [__] out of
the lady from T-Mobile the video clip
that I was watching earlier because the
lady from T-Mobile is like
the phone towers are gonna pick up the
strongest signal not necessarily the
closest signal to where they're at so I
can't exactly tell you like because
they're trying to say that his cell
phone wasn't his type of [__] what he's
only double murder or all the little
Clips I keep I see him on Trials I'm
like smiling and making little like
janky little smiles and [__] really it's
a weird thing to watch if I was on trial
for my life
maybe smiling he's like I didn't do this
[__] I'm getting off
could you imagine
oh
damn double murder that's sad bro he's
only 24 years old so oh yeah he's facing
the death penalty damn
what how did he kill him
was it bad did he stab him up or what
happened all right oh okay so it took
place in back in 2018 yeah he was 18.
Tried by shooting uh
yeah they're trying to use that cell
phone data to put it against him it
didn't really seem like it was going
great from the footage that I watched
well that it doesn't prove I don't know
if this dude's real last name is demons
or not but I think it is
somebody's last name initiate is demons
well yeah all kinds of [__] I thought
you might know about this dude I never
heard of his music or anything but uh I
don't pay attention to [__] dude this
Fool's trial is kind of like it seems
like it's kind of Taken on like all the
qualities of that uh why I saw a trial
like oh yeah he's still in jail too
there's a lot of fools in jail right now
that sucks
there's a lot of court cases Marty it's
a [__] lot not to mention your boy
pushing peas like it's like oh the uh
the rapper gonna yeah I never really
listened to him before but all I know is
everybody thinks that he snitched on
people because he got out I also think
that he said something to get out of a
jail early and the other people who are
still in jail sounds like you did
something different
I don't know what you did sounds like
something different happened is the
world accepting him back in I have no
idea I don't know I don't pay attention
I didn't really listen to him the world
accepted our Kelly back a bunch of times
R Kelly is in prison he's never coming
back but I'm saying he had a couple
waves where he did come back I feel like
oh yeah yeah oh you know what I saw this
morning Vlad TV is on a podcast and they
ask him a question and he says he has an
R Kelly interview on release he's not
going to put out he said he interviewed
him last week in prison over the phone
he said he interviewed him and he told R
Kelly he's not going to put it out
because R Kelly all he wanted to talk
about was conspiracies on why he's there
oh [__] I would still be interested to
see that I guess it sounds crazy but uh
[__] R Kelly it must have been real bad
for him to not want to put that [__] out
because he'll post [__] anything R
Kelly's a piece of [__] yeah of course
one one drop of that is true
yeah oh my God my kids uh still like to
sing I believe I can fly or you know all
that type of [__] like bro I always
forget that's R Kelly this reminds me of
the beginning of space Bill Cosby always
everybody got to be such a goddamn creep
sucks dude but yeah R Kelly [__] R Kelly
um
piss on you I mean if they were openly
making fun of it with Dave Chappelle and
took 20 more years for him to go to jail
it's true insane like it was common
knowledge almost like joke [__] insane
but yeah there's like this YouTuber dude
I was watching there was people just
kind of dedicated their channels and
[__] to cover and all the crazy [__]
going on in these trials you want to
know more details about that [__] oh
[__]
yeah yeah
um I honestly I don't think I could put
my time into a trial some people really
like I remember like the Casey Anthony
trial like stuff like I can't stand when
people make [__] their whole life
you know that again do your thing I
don't give a [__] do you I could care
less I don't care when people do that
I'm gonna continue with my life and you
do your thing over there because if you
think that that's the most important
thing in your life that's insane
the [__] that whatever the deed is is
dead it's done you're not changing
anything you know you could do Watch the
last episode I always do that for Rosie
Rosie can we watch this the last episode
of this [__] murder mystery [__]
please
12-part episode to find out the [__] I
called in minute seven
the prime suspect was this man since he
had blood on his dick man he's probably
the one that did it probably the guy
that did it at the end and they found
out that that blood was the blood from
the girl bro
the blows on his dick yeah we knew it
was him
I [__] hate murder mystery trial
[__] Rosie loves it I'm so [__] I
hate it I hate it so much yeah I've
almost kind of figured it out at me and
April's life she stays up later than me
so I kind of make her ever like force it
to after I go to sleep nice
okay yeah which was nice like what
you're really gonna sit here and watch
this [__] as you fall asleep I just
don't like hearing people get hurt like
it's like and then they cut her leg off
like bro she was just at home cooking
that's [__] up
I want to hear about this sad
at all not even a little
out to me listen to the most violent
games
I'm over here listen to necro talking
about crazy [__] I don't worry about
people getting hurt I caught his cut his
wrist kid
um sorry go ahead
I don't know if you saw this that means
what is happening with this what's going
on
I think that was our last [__] what
is what is that thing what is happening
with that
so from what I read about this pod this
little pod ship the Titan submarine this
dude was given tours of the Titanic
but like this is him in this video right
here and he goes that little green
button he's like this is the only button
for it and we control it with this
PlayStation controller
he's literally got like some sort of
[__] his submarine yeah okay it's
like literally a [__] Dreamcast
controller or some [__] okay so what's
the pro what happened so him and I think
four passengers went down there like a
billionaire dude some other people
millionaire went down there to tour the
Titanic ruins and they went missing
so the whole thing yeah
so I was watching this like how deep is
it it's [__] deep they said how deep
it is hold on
what what's happening out here what did
they find the Purple Heart
about 13 000 feet oh miles down
wow how'd they even find it
so miles are down 370 nautical miles how
the [__] long is a nautical mile off the
coast in Newfoundland okay oh
Newfoundland they got some big dogs so
they were saying that either they got
tangled up
down there
oh it couldn't back out and they're
caught in the wreckage which is like
best case scenario
but
we're filming this Wednesday the video
the expert that I found was like we have
until about Wednesday if that's the case
because they're gonna run out of air so
there's no GPS on it apparently not
um
but uh the other option being that they
sprung a [__] leak
which obviously you know dead yeah and
why don't they just go down there
it's not hard to to find it it's in the
water or it's not Canadian aircraft
searching the Atlantic Ocean detected
intermittent banging noises from the
vicinity of its last known
last known location
crew searching uh banging sounds I don't
know how you could hear something and
not be close enough to find it like that
yeah
searching for these people's lives and
guys cut his dick hair
yeah anyway so the whole family is so
sad and they're worried dick hair ad
hopefully they find them soon
uh yeah so we're gonna file this under
reasons why we don't go do keep deep sea
cave diving to be honest [__]
calling [__] you heard banging
yeah I mean like while you're in a plane
you heard banging
that's like the headline on all these
headlines is hearing banging noises I'm
gonna call [__] and that billionaire
had a new patent on a drug and they took
that [__] ship and killed these fools
on an island somewhere that's all or
they're down there going they're right
there point the camera up we can't find
them they're right there
oh I have a billionaires anywhere near
me when I'm away from me yeah that's a
fair [__] point there could be a
whole movie plot going on yeah
something's going on billionaires and
you just get lost you you hover above
the spot the nautical longitude and then
you go down
as a motor so you're gonna move straight
down you're not gonna [__] Coast away
three miles
you go down and look and if it's not
there it's not there if I'm in a
billionaire I'm not getting in a dude's
submarine with a PS5 controller they're
operating it too I'm gonna call [__]
what else is going on right now that
this needs to be on the headlines
another fair point what else is
happening so [__] random this is not
Titanic 2.
this is not a news thing this is like a
entertainment thing
I don't they didn't die I hope they
didn't die I hope so come on that's sad
IA whale swallowed them
I saw a video of a Surfers getting
swallowed by a [__] whale like two
weeks ago horrifying crazy [__] I'm like
a
paddle board yeah I saw it too oh no
thanks
thank you people are so casual out there
like it could just you could be in it
now can I talk about this on the show
about my Uber driver and the sharks
no real quick real quick real quick
sorry rant City Red City
I get into this car I'm an Uber
guys cool we're talking and he goes
um I get where you live he goes well
actually I live two weeks a year two
weeks I live in Hawaii I'm like all
right Trent and basically because Trent
he does the same thing and I go oh
that's cool man and he goes yeah I'm
actually uh I'm leaving in two days I'm
gonna propose to my girlfriend and we're
talking I was like oh [__] yeah that's
cool man he's like 60 year old dude
right I'm like sick man he's a white guy
am I cool what what do you used to do
before Uber and then he starts going in
about history and all this [__] about
the company he and his four friends and
Company have a patent on shark repellent
and they think they got it down it's a
frequency that's a little pack that you
put on your hip or in a life vest
in a headset in a goggle anything
and a sense of frequency out and it
makes sharks [__] bounce they hate
the frequency they leave except tiger
sharks he's like still tiger sharks
there's little bastards keep going past
it he's like and then he started talking
1941 the governor U.S government uh Navy
started developing this and they still
haven't got it Down Right blah blah and
they told me about the history there was
some um
secret mission on this in the 40s or 60s
and uh an American ship right listen to
this [__] guys an American ship
started sinking with like a thousand
[__] soldiers on it and all of them
almost got eaten by sharks
Perot over the course of like two and a
half days oh God they sank and they were
floating with their life as yeah and
there's some survivors they tell their
stories and
Pro it's sad because they're like you
know one guy got bit and now there's
blood everywhere and then sharks start
freaking out and he's like dude you're
flown there for two and a half days
and you just hear screams periodically
people screaming and you hear water
splashing and then non-stop five people
get eaten to death real quick next to
you and then you're just hoping you're
not gonna get pulled down next and
there's a bunch of your [__] homies
just getting eaten alive next to you for
two days
and he told that story he's like that's
the reason why they started that they
was like they could never happen again
like this is great which is insane get
the [__] out the water bro let's bunch
of little lions in there no thank you
and uh
that and I can't remember you guys will
know the name Google it I just read that
story online on Twitter or some [__] bro
it's so sad my Uncle John told me about
that [__] a long time ago too it's so
sad man
oh anyway
um
he's talking to me telling me they
developed you know the shark repellent
[__]
and I'm over here telling them like good
[__] [__] that I'm not getting in the
water blah blah blah and he's like yeah
we're just marketing about and I and I
told him what I always say and I go hey
how about this
it's like I know the odds are very low
if you get bit by a shark go hey [__]
the odds I was like what about these
odds how many people say you won't get
bit by a shark what are the odds an
ocean that you're gonna get bit by a
shark and I said what if you go to the
park and there's a sign that says there
might be a lion here
very odd chances low chances that you
get attacked by a lion but not none
there's a percentage that you could get
eaten alive
we have those signs up at the parks by
my house
for mountain lions are you serious yeah
yeah I know I know when you say that it
seems extreme but really like there's no
mountain lines are rampant out here in
La too so tell Rosie uh
[__] are strapped on Hikes for
that reason
I'll let her go out no [__] that shoot
something in the face
and uh
[Music]
I told him that and he stopped looked at
me
and say can I please use that for our
marketing I go [__] run it and I go
one day I'm gonna see it and I'm so
happy like I [__] I'm like Forrest
Gump
here's your shirt
have a nice day
that that's one of the greatest moments
if I just saw the picture on it Twitter
some [__] of the dude that Drew that
we had actually did it yeah how much do
you pay by Walmart not a lot no no I
don't think it was very much he's
definitely got he's billionaire for sure
off that if he uh hold on I guarantee
you that man's a billionaire Marty
calling it billionaire got it Rose Molly
what's his net worth
how much money is he made he looks like
a demon
that guy drove have a nice what stop
does look like he has no expression on
his face and he's the one that Drew that
Harvey ball get a smile on your face
are you [__] kid oh he's with the
depression never mind he can be sad
looking
was that net worth Marty the net worth
didn't pot nothing came up
it's there how much money has the smiley
face generated guys I'm sorry for this
right now we never applied for a
trademark for the iconic Smiley image
and only earned forty five dollars for
his efforts is what the first paragraph
of his Wikipedia says
I'm a [__] shoot somebody if he
didn't get paid
guys this episode
Grant City
rat city but you know what perfect when
Harvey ball was hired by an insurance
company in 1963 to create a morale
boosting icon for its employees
they made
I mean [__] they weren't even talking
about it being a marketing thing you
should see how much money has the smiley
made okay okay
not not him because he's a [__] dummy
he got paid 45 for the most iconic [__]
in the world
500 million dollars a year God knows I
mean how do you even they Market it they
they licensed into Walmart Oh okay
that's what I'm saying how much they get
paid that's the bouncing face in Walmart
oh that's why Walmart's pop and remember
those commercials in the early 2000s
where the face would knock down prices
commercials really solidified Brands
back then can you think of a cool Target
ad [__] no you can't
you can think of a cool Walmart ad and
that's the one McDonald's hard as hell
they used to go the hardest Taco Bell
remember that
was a good commercials man in the last
trial
yeah I think that's our last trial what
was the last one again
ynw Maui
damn oh no Titanic oh yeah Titanic that
wasn't a trial though I mean I guess it
could news headline Titanic man that's
sad I hope they're alive Also let's move
on to something else I have a little
story right a little story for you guys
I'm a look I'm gonna look straight at
this [__] camera to tell you
um real quick guys I went to a weed
event the other day real fun awesome I
haven't been to a good weed event with a
lot of people in a long time I've been
to smaller events but not one that has
that many people it was cool it's
non-stop meeting fans it was awesome as
hell I met so many people took hella
pictures it was dope as hell the reason
I'm bringing this up because I have a
very odd interaction that happened but
awesome
so you know I'm just talking to fans
walking around trying to get to the
booth check out some [__] all good
trying to walk back into a building at
like two hours after I've been there
trying to walk back into a building but
it's so congested people trying to get
through to show their wristband the
guards are taking their time
so people just start going under the
railing to the right and going around
the around the entrance and going
straight in
I'm like dude after I saw the 30th
person do it I'm like all right I'm just
gonna do it too I crawl under the thing
then crawl by a duck under the thing
and I'm starting to walk and I'm
starting to walk back into the event
kind of like into the main part
and I see some dude look at me and
obviously you know I'm taking a picture
with fans and [__] and he goes push
straight I'm like yo what up man
and it's a white dude
um long hair kind of like a skater
looking dude random tattoos everywhere
looked high as [__] looked high as hell
I look at him like what's up man and he
goes I'm your lawyer
and I'm like nah
they go nah
because I thought like maybe he's so
high he's like I I want to be your
lawyer
you know or if you think like yo maybe
he thinks I'm somebody else but he
didn't say push trees and he goes I'm
your lawyer and I went nah
like okay no you're not and also know if
you're trying to be my lawyer weird
place to ask me as I'm like rushing he
was about to crawl under the thing too
so I'm like bro
what the [__]
and he goes I'm your lawyer nah
because then I start thinking I've never
met my lawyer in person you know that
it's all been over the phone I made it
through my CPA my accountant and he's
just my lawyer for you know trademark
this this little stuff stuff that I need
quick lawyer stuff and his name is his
name is Anton and I'm like looking at
this guy you don't look like an answer
at all you don't
at all you're a white dude with a
covered in tattoos beard he looked like
he made hash
and then he goes for push trees I'm your
lawyer I'm like no because I'm like
you're no you're not I have one lawyer
and then I guess this is an announcement
and he goes no with tea
am I why do you know that name or that
well who who are you he goes I'm your
lawyer for push trees cannabis company
so we're starting to push these cannabis
companies coming very soon we're getting
all legalities in the out of the way
never met my partner's lawyer his
personal Lord never met him I know he's
a fan
he already knew watched my [__] when my
friend approached him about this thing
he goes bro for real yeah I watched that
guy's [__] rarely wow how odd the lawyer
just watched my shoes remember that how
cool
and then he's like
I'm your lawyer for push and I realize
like
oh you really are my lawyer
oh I'm the high ass one I'm I'm walking
in a line as he's walking with me
talking because there's a bunch of
people like no he's like no your push is
like no
I'm like half walking like what's up man
because I'm like yo who's this dude
she's like I don't want you to be my
lawyer bro if you're asking me yeah he
goes for push trees and I go and I say
my home my partner's name I go shut the
[__] up my bro nice to meet she goes
nice to meet you in person finally man
he said we're wrapping everything up
like
uh it was it's so loud I look at him
and I just go I'm so glad this is what
you look like this is awesome and he
goes
yeah man nice to meet you man I have fun
I'm like good [__] and what I meant by
that was
you're a lawyer you're doing you're
doing everything we need but this is
what you look like you look like you're
gonna board slide up
somewhere and like hippie flip your
board somewhere I swear to God he looked
like one of the guys from Lords of
Dogtown and I looked at him like you're
our lawyer that's dope nice but I never
thought I'd I'd I just thought it was
the odd thing I'm your
oh you are after a minute it was the it
was just so weird 20 minutes before that
I'm walking through the crowd some dude
walks up to me and by look on his face
I'm like oh okay we'll say you watch my
[__] what's up dude you know what I mean
I'm like yo what up what up and uh
dude
guy walks up to me he goes what's up man
here
puts me on speaker with my partner
that the other that the uh
with my partner that I'm my lawyer
remember
because he has a different business
and his partner happened to be there and
just saw me and he was on the phone with
my partner this is very confusing let's
just say t Okay this random dude was on
the phone with t as he's walking by and
he goes
yo I just saw your boy he walks like yo
say this up we go well who is it man
like what's up dude he's like he puts a
phone and I go what's up
because at first I'm like bro what the
[__] put a phone in my face like that
what what's going on I'm not gonna just
talk to somebody I do it all the time
when I'm like yo can you please talk to
my homies at work he couldn't make it
yeah all the [__] time FaceTime with
fools at work that's fine
but just to go like this I was like what
the [__] I was like what's up man he
goes it's Tiago what
and he goes oh I'm T's partner and I go
oh
and then I recognize he looks so
different not in the grow you know I
mean look way different at a careless
couple high and I'm like bro you look a
lot he's like I know look way different
yeah you look like a regular high-ass
dude just at the cup like I didn't
realize that was you and then I'm on the
phone like what's up yeah all right cool
and then 20 minutes later I was like our
lawyer I just thought it was really
funny wow
um shout out to 420 Julian 420 Julian
won our golden ticket from the
dopashop.com yep nice drove from Chicago
to go to that event nice I ran into him
right when I was leaving oh [__] never
met him yeah we haven't done the golden
ticket hit the golden ticket we're gonna
do the video in August he just came out
here for the event just how random bro
he Dr and as I was leaving we ran into
each other oh so he didn't even like I
didn't say that I was no no he was going
to the event like it was a cool dope
event he was just going then I look at
his homie and go
how do I know you say I know you
Indiana meet and greet and the New York
damn
I I knew it I'm like you have a hundreds
on your hat or like oh and hit three
cues on this hat oh I knew it was a
circle of some and I looked at I go I
know you and he goes yeah we met a few
I'm like my
and then I was walking through the crowd
I saw do with braids and I looked at him
he looked at me and go
Diamond chap puravita restaurant once
and he goes
yeah that's crazy remember that [__] I
met this dude randomly at a restaurant
like [__] eight months ago yes all
the corner of mine he's like yo
I can't take a picture I'm like yeah
he's like I just flew him from New York
right now we just came to get food and
like bro we both watch you we just
sitting next to you we didn't want to
bug him like bro say hi took a picture I
just saw my pass I'm gonna go
purvita right I don't know how my brain
connected it with the pattern on the
restaurant wall
and I went I know that image of you but
where was it you were to my right that's
why I remember [__] I think of like
where it was relative to where I was
thinking when I saw it it's when I saw
him I go now the braids you're really
big I remember standing up and you had a
little pervita and I remember right off
the bat bro but I just remember going
like yo my brain is insane it just went
[Music]
and found it one day I met some guy it
was nuts bro I just came through so many
archives little neural Pathways crazy
nuts I couldn't believe that I
remembered that but I can at the same
time but yeah anyway uh the event was
awesome met my lawyer
crazy I'm not like that it'll take me 10
times to remember somebody's name oh I
don't remember names [__] like that I
will not remember you know what I do I
started like six years ago
boom I just had your name in my head and
then I was gonna say it out loud I
always go in my head not to every person
but when I'm not sure I used to go
hey Michelle just said I'll [__] their
name up I knew it so often my brain
tries to convince me that I'm wrong and
it's actually it'll throw out a couple
other names that it might be that's why
I say it in my head first and if I don't
uh
is this a wreck also you're I just once
again once again once again if this is
incredible can we see it from the front
ready
it's not not terrible but yeah I got
something from my side oh you have an
eighth worth of efforts that's crazy I
moved this and then I saw the mo I
didn't know that was there and then I
saw all of it if you can't see you're
driving Marty is essentially a chimney
sweep from Mary Poppins and his entire
side is just ash
that's you right now
well this was over here
but everywhere at the show that's
incredible it's even all the way over
there has [__] there was that monster
it was doing it it was that's what she
said
um so yeah that was that that's what
happened it was great it was [__]
awesome I got some things on my phone
hold on hold on hold on you got a big uh
we got a
hour and a half Story Time dropping
tomorrow ooh hour and a half Story Time
dropping so if you're watching this go
watch the dopasiola channel hour and a
half episode
taking a little wild it's getting a
little wild all right uh we brought up
some fan questions yes I got two right I
wanted I'm gonna ask you this this is
from Yousef mad
throughout the throughout the years of
creating content I know there were times
you asked yourself is it even we're
continuing to push through I'm sure you
asked yourself is it ever going to work
out what allowed you to push through and
continue to start to keep circulating in
your brain and the reason you decided
not to stop I know this is a question we
probably answered in very different ways
before
but I mean I'm not gonna speak for you
but obviously you have children yeah
so many so many so like for you it's
obviously like well I'm not gonna I feel
bad enough when Ariana just walked
outside of the [__] and I didn't
watch her what happens when I'm like yo
I can't pay for your stuff it's really
scary
um so I think for you
I think the question is not the music
because we know that story
can you stop the music because you're
like dudes graphic [__] is hard dope
yeah what kind of because you could have
got any job you could have started a
business in the phones you could have
did anything what wanted what made you
want to keep
your foot in the door with comedy as
soon as you got in there well it would
have been it would have been way way way
easier less stressful for my whole
family if I would have gotten a regular
job that had health insurance and took
out taxes and had a study paycheck and
that just
uh was that was just never my path like
I literally always knew that I I just
couldn't I couldn't do that I knew I had
to do that for a while but like I've
always been an artist April knew that
like she kind of knew what she signed up
for as far as that goes and it was
really just not in really just wasn't an
option like I have a lot of skills that
I could go get a day job with but like
that really has never been an option
because I know that it's capped so it's
like that's what we sign up for it's
like you're somebody who bets on that
you can go get way more than you could
to be comfortable at some like cat
position by go doing your own thing so
but it like right around the time I met
you would have been a fork in the road I
think because even though I had it like
accomplished
everything I could and it's so hot it
was in comedy which is something I love
just as much as music and should so it
was like I really did it but I took it
to the biggest level I think that one
person really could and it was like
I needed I needed to start over again
like we said in the Ted talk with this
and start from scratch in a lot of ways
and that's just kind of I understand now
that that's almost normal and that's
what it takes where it's like it kind of
comes about in chapters and then you
kind of reset in some ways but
it's just not in the mix for me you know
I've always
I've always been like it's the harder
route it's definitely not easier but
it's the path I signed up for yeah and
the idea is that it pays off in the long
run
way more so because I would be chilling
in my 40s and 50s
not even just chilling doing sick [__]
yeah exactly which is kind of like
chilling because it's like so dope yeah
all right I see you so hold on bring me
back to what the original question was
again one time
how hard could Thomas dunk on you sorry
oh no different question no I'm saying
what made you want to keep uh like
pushing your creators yeah even when you
were like you know I hated the day the
day job took so much for my soul like I
can't express how much I hated day jobs
but that was it like that was such fuel
to never ever go back to the cubicle
never have to fake who I am again for
the majority of the day that's what did
it like I hated it so much
that I had to build up
skills enough to like be able to support
myself once I realized like oh I'm not
going to get probably some huge million
dollar deal
music how can I use these skills
otherwise so that in and of itself was
almost a pivot yeah I was waiting for
the huge payday
you know but it's tough though you got
to know what you're signing up for
there's you know there's a lot to be
said about having a career that takes
you on the path of a regular job that
has security and benefits and all that
type of [__] this is like an unorthodox
thing we got going on but
it's just is who we are
yeah uh basically what you said is um
like for like when I first started I
mean I've always thought like you know
I'm gonna be a [__] billionaire one
day but how I don't know yet but I'll
get there
I always thought that even though I
always knew that's real even though in
my present day if you talk ask me like
bro I'm broke I don't know how to make
money you want to make 30 000 how the
[__] do you do that legally
that's what I thought every day
illegally like I got you I can do some
math
it's gonna take a while
might take a little bit unless people
just want to break some [__] down I can
do that with weed weeds different I have
something people want
if you want it I'll sell it to you
I think for me when I started doing
content
I never looked at it as like yo you know
what's crazy is I know
that I'll be rich as [__] one day I
never thought it was from that I was
like I know I'm gonna do something I'm
gonna do something where I can buy my
[__] family out and do [__] and help
everybody
even though if you ask me I would like
there's no way I'm gonna ever make money
that's [__] stupid I'm just doing
this because I really think it's fun
that's how my brain know thinks but like
my inner me is like bro we're gonna be
balling get out of here yeah but if you
ask me like with a gun in my head like
bro I'm broke
I'm possible how do I make that much
money I would never [__] understand
you have to be like that yeah but in my
inner thought yeah like not even me like
on mushrooms me I'm like of course I'm
going to yeah but my I think my ego is
self-conscious belly problem that's
impossible how do you make that much
money ow but you have to have that
within you somewhere and it goes it
doesn't matter I don't know but it is
who yeah it doesn't matter I'm gonna get
it somewhere it is what I am this is
what I do like but if you ask me I'm
like no I'm not gonna be a billionaire
you know how much you want a billion
dollars do I make oil you know what I
mean but now that I think about it I
just speak it out like yeah of course I
will but I don't know how I'll get there
I started getting into that but before
when I first started Instagram like Pro
I hopefully make enough money off shirts
maybe that's what I was thinking I hope
you make enough money off shirts to make
to not struggle because I was struggling
for not eight years straight
but we like started getting deleted
that's when I was like bro what am I
doing why is it why am I this is not
even [__] fair you know I mean before
that I was just gaining a following but
then it was like oh I gained all this
falling for it to be taken and there's
so many times like bro what am I doing
the question was what makes you want to
keep doing it
is
I've never
like growing up I was like you know
[__] not
awesome to everyone else's eyes I guess
I thought I was [__] with [__]
everyone's like this [__] lame ass
kid or whatever it was or make fun of me
and [__] who cares
the fact that people hit me up are like
bro I'm thinking of that this this not
for the podcast when I was just doing
pictures and [__] like yo this is it
makes me [__] laugh this is like what
I do all day thank you Byron the [__]
I'm making pictures now I'm like oh
that's [__] awesome and then it got
to the point where I started getting
like a big following and people were
like bro you make you help my [__]
[__] fourth period I [__] can't
stand that [__] I'm just watching your
stories I'm like oh that's thank you
thank you for passing the time or be at
work with bro I'm just on my break thank
you [__] I'm so bored that's When Fools
and then DMS came and when DMS were here
I was like started talking to people for
real
people didn't want to put their business
out in the comment
and then when people were like yo you
[__] are when they're literally like
bro you are my [__] Simpsons I don't
know what I would do if you have your
channel I [__] hate YouTube or I
don't watch YouTubers this is a whole
different type of YouTube
as like not even YouTube it's just a
show of your life at one point like The
Truman Show I'm like whoa that's [__]
wild but when people like bro
you some of the [__] you've said has
made me think different and when people
actually give a [__] that's what makes
me like bro I'm so broke but look at
these look at this [__] I always show
Rosie the crazy nice people I'm like
look at these [__] people this is the
dopest yeah we say it off like we're the
nicest [__] fans on the planet this
is a dope you're just going through the
comments before right it's like [__] man
people are so damn nice they're so dope
and
I think that's why I've never stopped
doing it even though I kept getting Liam
I do one day I'd always say people like
yo you getting deleted like one day's
gonna pay off one day they won't you
probably see me comment that one day
it'll stop or one day it won't matter or
one day this [__] platform's gonna be
so small like I'll remember oh Mary you
should get deleted a lot wow she was old
and I always thought like one day I'll
get past it but mainly what it is is
dude and then then I started meeting
fans in person and then the meet and
greets I'm like what the [__]
because what 2022 My Views did this I
started getting Shadow banned and all
this [__] every video I put out and it's
hard for a person that makes content not
to go what am I doing different
you know what I mean when you have the
same Vibe going in the video like how
come this one doesn't work
do people not [__] with it and then it
happens consistently for five months I'm
like
people not like my [__] anymore damn
well that sucks I still love making
videos so I kept pumping them out and
then I'm like damn I guess my videos are
dying a little bit that's sad
I love making videos but you know what
it's cool I'll still make videos and
then when I went to the meet and greets
I was like oh
it really is just some Shadow band and
they really are [__] with my views
because what the other one that wasn't
Shadow Man the other day yeah did my
normal numbers 160 in the first day like
bro thank you thank you for my view and
then I got interested in outside 120 I
mean 162 dropped views yeah it's like
it's a little bit higher than what it
was anyway
when I met the fools in person and I
meet people everywhere all the time but
I'm saying when it was a concentrated
thing
and I saw that many [__] people
outside like
you guys are waiting here for 15 hours
this is not just YouTube yeah this is
not a YouTube this is going to be in 30
years when fools are 35 going hey full
run into me at a store like
their kids like who the [__] is that guy
like yo what's up bro how you doing like
yo this is
Chong you don't know who Chong is it's
20 60. yeah you know like sorry he was
the funniest man in the in the 1980s
they're gonna have talked about Chong
like the way we talk about Chong now
like yo he's like the older man he's the
[__] they're gonna be talking about me
like that one day so that's what makes
me think like
[__] yeah sick as hell hopefully you
know I mean hopefully I'm still doing
everything I want to do yeah I mean I
will be but
I think just people telling me that the
yo this helps me pass time or when I
start actually talking about some real
[__] and people I talk to people a lot
very very deep intimate [__] that I'm
like whoa we're running loading some
[__] in this car all right all right
let's talk and um
just dude is so sad not so sad it's so
wild that our videos to just just being
present can help I'm sure you talk to
people it's like damn dude that's really
[__] up that you're in that situation
but I'm happy that we're here to help
I've had fools so many people tell me
I'm not going to talk about other
business out here but a lot of
life-threatening [__] and it's like
I never thought I'd be able to be there
like yo chill that's what we're gonna do
talk to me tomorrow we'll talk about
this tomorrow just chill out go home you
know what I mean like
go talk to your parents type [__] or
your girlfriend and go hang out just
don't be rashed and it's like wow I
never thought I'd be able to [__]
help a [__] without even having
to meet you to have that much like to
have that much like impact on somebody
it's like wow that's why we're always
like let's get on to some positive [__]
I don't like this because like we could
be on some negative [__] right now and
you know what to do me talking [__]
about something because I'm pissed then
somebody's at home I see this even this
fool gets mad we all get mad and they
like be like Oh I'm gonna lash out I'm
not saying that we influence people to
go do things but if we can I would like
it to be in a good way totally
so I know it's a long rant but that's
what keeps me still doing stuff even
when I've never made money off dopejo
Channel
you know I mean so you knew that before
I was just like trying to make it happen
somehow I was like [__] I'd rather just
be broke and try to make it happen
because all these fools are waiting on
the on The Simpsons for some of these
people I'm like I can't not be there
because I look at YouTube I'm not trying
to talk [__] but I look at YouTube I'm
like yo we there's a lot of fans a lot
of Die Hard fans I don't see a lot of
communities where they're like yo I'm
gonna tell you this [__] YouTuber's
entire life right now and I can if you
ask me eight questions I'd be like yeah
he wouldn't do that he would never do
that he would do that for sure it's like
damn people really [__] know you
that's true people really do people come
on like what's up Thomas where's oh
what's up with Rocco I'm like wild
so awesome people like it's like a show
Almost but it's like like when I was on
live with Frank where's Marty at first
thing he asked where's Marty like oh
because you saw the background yeah I
saw the background I'm like oh he'll be
here like and then you showed 10 minutes
he'll be like 10 minutes he goes uh all
right man he's all Michael because we're
talking about Grand Theft Auto yeah and
then someone gonna be Michael the guy on
Friday and um
it's just that's why we hate making
content if we didn't make that much
money on this Marty you would have to
take you know some client do your thing
and can we just say isn't it kind of odd
that you were at the top Echelon of what
you could possibly be doing in your
field with the biggest artists
not just in your field in the world
it's kind of wild if you think about it
uh I think about it all the time when
people say something like
damn Marty did that wow it's just like
you never think about these things and
then you think about it and go oh holy
[__]
like that yeah like when you're on the
Super Bowl you're like I'm the [__]
Super Bowl set I was just [__]
throwing up a gang sign in [__]
Buffalo 10 years ago oh [__]
it's crazy if you think about it and
then you start thinking I hope
[__] do this [__] too and
that's what the whole show's about like
bro we used to [__] up I [__] up a lot
it's okay and uh
I just I don't know that's that's the
answer that question is
yeah sorry let me let me bring up the
next question to the day
to the [__] day
this week I'm going back to rough
[__] oh 10 years 10 years from the
time that we Sorry set off I was booked
Cheech Marin
no [__] just got it from the booking
let's go yeah yeah let's go we just got
chichar we just said we had Chung on now
we're getting cheat John let's go I
don't even know where you're working on
it I just I just I didn't either I got
it with 60 minutes ago I just looked to
my phone to bring up the next question
and said hey guys she's just asking if
he can come oh nice
I love when people they want us to
provide a car to pick them up like I'm
gonna pick them up a hot boxing in my
car but hey what's up man when we get
there like oh yeah
that would be a great way to start the
show wow so we just spilled the beans
but we got chunk I mean we got Cheech
coming in let's go you can talk to them
all about all his writing [__] I love
that we just close up that Tommy Tron
clip yesterday was so legendary
that's [__] awesome but let's do it
we're paying for his car okay yeah
whatever I told you they're asking if
you can provide a car of course yeah
gotcha
sorry that was awesome live on the show
see
[__] throw this [__]
we need we need Danny McBride Kenny
Powers on here too
okay sorry
I interviewed Cheech like four and a
half years ago oh I didn't know that
before I ever did an interview
um
yeah on this show they asked me to come
in like yeah we're gonna have chichon
and I rolled them like a zip joint I
wasn't smoking I was like I can't wait
to smoke it with him and I just right
when we started I'm like yeah
all right thanks man that's gonna be
great tonight thank you so much and he
put in his jacket I was like
um I meant to smoke it right now and
everybody that was there that knew what
I was planned it for they kind of looked
at me like just pocketed or [__] not
even the pocket is like oh I want you to
smoke it
okay
you stupid Alex I'm not gonna say a word
bro oh okay sorry next question from n
scott01
ready one of these guys
all right ready ready
what are we at what time
oh okay we need to cut it soon two
tennis Marty's moving I'm moving Marty's
leaving to Buffalo tomorrow guys 10
years to the day since you've been back
so no since I left
oh since you moved yeah oh Ariana turn
five on her uh on our drive out no so I
was like yeah exactly 10 years
to the weak to the [__] like we hit
the road on like the 24th or 25th
so
damn that's weird that's really weird
because uh yeah when I get there we're
staying right next to like where my mind
used to live at when April's friend's
house
so it's weird yeah oh it's gonna be a
weird time warp for you yeah I wasn't
looking forward to it I you know it's
gonna be all right but yeah man I
remember I I like we had the U-Haul
packed my mom's on the porch I was just
like I'm Gonna Make It Happen she's like
I know hugged her and that was it
drove off into the [__] sunset with
all our [__] in a Airbnb ahead of us
wow 10 years later
um
10 years of my mind was like the real
like if I get 10 years between me and
buffalo I'll have kind of established
myself
weird but dude to the week that is
awesome yeah seeing it here I'm so happy
we this was everything I could have
imagined like best case scenario by far
the way everything's coming together
way back when
when everything seemed [__] hopeless
and I was convincing myself I was a
[__] billionaire
and nobody looked at me like I was crazy
like this is best case scenario so sick
go back to the to the tent that's insane
yeah
all right so you're gonna go back you're
gonna be gone for a couple days yeah ten
years to the day which is insane to me
yeah I just think 10 years ago what's
what is it the 23 2013 June
I was in my yard taking pictures for
Instagram
it's Rocco's Rocco's birthday was
yesterday
so I would have got him he's a little
kid at that point 10 years ago he was
nine playing with him doing something oh
got those heads though he saw that I saw
that he did it on purpose he said shut
the [__] up yeah I was doing some weed
[__] wow
um
oh sorry sorry so Marty will be back
guys we'll be back and John's almost
ready the little jerk
oh
a little fast and you're supposed to be
here today we got to do it next week so
the Hash House episodes coming soon
don't worry
um I'm so sorry for that it's gonna be
fun
ready and scott01 if you could say
something to the entire world and they'd
hear at the same time but only in their
heads and Scott you're high as hell
because if everyone in the world could
hear it
wouldn't it be cool just to play it out
loud so they could hear it are you
saying because some people are deaf they
would only hear it in their head I'm
high you know what no that was
complexity that was very complex in
their head but only in their heads what
would it be how about this if you could
say something the entire world and
they'd all hear it in their head at the
same time what would it be
nice wow Marty that's why you're my
friend you know what I'm gonna say don't
be mean
in verse
or
we could all possibly be friends like
And subscribe
[Laughter]
I was gonna save my cash app
like And subscribe is incredible
I don't think I could have wrote
something [__] more perfect that was
unbelievable what's the one thing you
can say the whole world new episodes
every 12 at 12 30 everyone
YouTube's being a [__] so make sure you
make sure you click it up and get the
notifications shout out to Spotify
oh right as soon as we end this episode
me and Marty are going to start a new
series guys we're starting a new series
in which we're gonna break down our
Spotify playlists we're gonna break down
a couple artists every episode so
Marty's gonna bring three I'm gonna
bring three or five whatever it is give
you a little breakdown of the artist why
we like this song or what a song and
it's basically like yo [__] you probably
haven't heard of or [__] you have heard
of by the way we like the same [__] kind
of like a music breakdown me and Marty
go hard with the music
and people always say what do you guys
listen to what's your playlist like we
uh you ask guests what's your Spotify
playlist like you ask them often
so that's what we're gonna do and we'll
break down a little thing I mean [__] it
sounds cool and shout out to Spotify she
had Spotify for making this official
business partners
yeah
boy if you hear our voices on a
commercial it is us if you want to go
ahead and follow us on Spotify that
would be a good look dude where was that
100K but even though they had followers
on Spotify thank you literally It's So
Dope um
so that series is starting right after
this and then Marty that was the quest
oh yeah if you could say everything in
the whole earth only here in their heads
all at the same time what would it be
there it is all right don't be mean
Marty be nice
don't be an [__]
goes a long way [__] uh truly does
um
oh last little thing last little thing I
know this is a rant City episode but
real quick I'm gonna talk to you guys
I forgot to tell you you ready uh I went
to the Wiz and friends thing the other
day I went to wisdom Friends Wiz Khalifa
does this thing he like does a like a
mansion or Airbnb or whatever in the
Hills
they'll have all the camera set up in
the game they're playing games on Twitch
and smoking it's like a little event
right
so uh him and Snoop asked my homie
because my homie knows he's part of the
Taylor game they said hey we know you
know that guy Thomas obagiola please ask
him to come
so I was like damn this was ask me all
right let's go
I pull up
and remember it's the day that the Josh
Wolf episode's happening so I have a
hard out
how am I gonna tell these high [__]
I got a hard out
I have to leave by 3 30 it starts at one
and it goes till seven
I'm pretty much getting there before
anyone gets there I showed up as like
one of the first 20 people there so I
walked in
and I see a bunch of like cameras and
screens but I don't see anybody I see
legs only on a couch because all the
screens are covering and I just walk
there's a boost you know companies I
walk to the backyards a bunch of people
outside
I see a Jacuzzi with a top and I
immediately set up all my dab [__] all
of it I brought everything you can think
of and I kind of felt like a dick but I
set up like as if I had a booth there
was companies there with booth and I had
my own booth basically
me and John are taking down smoking
so like an hour and a half goes by Wiz
Khalifa's still doing his thing playing
games and uh that's the event what game
is it I don't know I I didn't know but
they're playing games doing [__] I saw
Chevy Woods like he said so what up uh
Chevy Woods was on the show check out
his episode it was awesome and um
you know
chilling and I'm not gonna go walk up
while they're filming hey what's up
what's up man thanks for inviting me get
out of the shop like bro whenever you're
done I'll say hi to you if I don't see
you we'll meet another time thank you
for the invite I just want to show up
say thank you for inviting me
it's getting close to the time where I
have to leave Joshua it's getting real
close where I have to leave you're
sitting around dabbing the whole time
just dabbing and smoking Choppers of
joints but John okay
and you know
what's going on it's going along I have
a customized the dopest Wiz Khalifa box
for him we made his own sick ass
subscription box but Wiz Khalifa's [__]
all over it nice but I was like yo I'm
gonna have to give it to your camera guy
to give to you because you're still
filming I'm not gonna go up there and
bug you hey yeah hey stream here's my
dopest box that is never gonna be me
right yeah plus I just want to give it
to you if you don't like it just [__]
throw it away bro it's just I gave it to
you in my head
yeah
thank you for inviting me right
I leave it's time to go never even saw
Wiz Khalifa I saw him as I walked out
because he was playing games still never
met him nothing my homie even texted me
he's like yo DJI after that right yeah
and like two days later
Ryan's like yo you have fun I'm like
yeah man I was like I just stabbed my
ass off honestly because you wait
you didn't you guys didn't smoke and
like you weren't on stream
what do you mean he goes it bro you're
supposed to like be up by where the
couch is you're supposed to be on stream
oh nobody told me anything I just didn't
want to be like hey you know who I am I
need to be sitting here with you guys
like I'm not gonna do that
ever I just sat in the backyard with
John and got high said nothing to
anybody basically unless they came up to
me I met Snoop Dogg's gaming team they
were cool and uh
[__] I'm like nah nah he goes bro are
you serious and he goes okay that's why
he said that
no before he even told me that the
gaming part sorry he goes I'm like yeah
he's like wait
you didn't go on the Stream
oh sorry I just I just said that sorry
he goes hey how was it I'm like oh it's
cool it's like so how was it you guys
really you guys click like would you
chill or wait I didn't meet him he goes
what are you saying and he goes well as
manager you're supposed to meet will go
I only met Dan
photographer
and he goes oh my God and he goes damn
it he's like whiz called me and he's
like yo the event was dope he goes where
where's up with that guy Thomas that
YOLO dude never showed up
Wiz call Ryan to go yo how come that
fool Yola never came to the party
well specific Ally was waiting waited
for me to come get high and I had no
idea that I was supposed to go into the
room and sit and get high with them and
stream yeah I had no clue they are
supposed to have a guy that kind of
walks you I missed that guy yeah I
missed that guy damn
so he calls me goes bro he even said
where was Thomas the dobiziola he's like
I was waiting to meet him I never saw
him
and he's like you went right and I'm
like yeah that's why I said yeah it was
cool I dab my ass off he's like okay but
you win I'm like what are you asking me
if I went of course I went like
dude you were supposed oh he's like bro
come on not to me but he's like in
general how did nobody guide you to this
to filming yeah I had no idea I just sat
in the backyard and dabbed with John for
two and a half hours when I was supposed
to be here on street with this man I had
no idea because I met Chevy was right
when I walked he's almost like I'll see
you and I went all right Ximena I'll see
you inside oh God I will see you inside
you should go get miked or something
yeah [__] that does make sense
so
I just thought it was funny like wait he
called you and said he goes bro you
asked me he's like where when Thomas
dope he's like dope why didn't he come
he's like I thought he was coming
and he's like you went right and that's
me said dude you're supposed to be on
stream then everything I just said I'm
sorry I said that after I said the last
part first that's what confused my own
brain it's like Paul I just said that
but yeah that's what happened I thought
it was really funny and he's like yo I'm
coming to town next month we'll just go
to his house I'm like that sounds like a
lot better of a way to beat somebody
let's just go to his house again
[__] wrecked
my goal
is panic attacks that's it okay I want
to be the guy that made with the
Cleveland go bro I don't no no no no no
I'm good give me some time that's what I
want to be that guy you're gonna put him
onto that panic attack [__] you told me
about oh yo yo shout out to Kush Clinic
I went there yesterday you guys have
heard the brand elephant growth I told
you some of the best OG ever smoked
there's uh they squished it they made
raw they squished the hash they made
rosin of it let me say this right now
I haven't gotten genuinely stupid high
in a long time
I dab that rosin
and I had a mini panic attack second
pull
second pull my brain got overwhelmed my
lungs and I went can I finish this am I
breathing and I'm like and I looked I
told you I looked at the ball like no
I'm breathing
that hasn't happened in so long I got so
damn high off the OG rosin there's only
88 jars on the Earth
it's the most exclusive drop besides the
zeusi drop and I bought
let's just say
it's a 350 gram
and I know about you but you paid that
let's just let's not be a dick no I
didn't pay the retail price or I'm not
gonna say what I paid shout out to coach
Clinton for being nice to me
it's charging for 350 a zip so it's just
I'm in a gram sorry a zip a gram as I
scooped it up well that's a 65 data
that's insane
and it's not the expensiveness it's the
exclusivity of that strain is not
produced a lot and it's washed John was
explaining to me that ogs don't they
don't yield a lot they don't yield too
so you've got to charge for that and the
fact that they're like yo you made rosin
out of it
I'm gonna how much how much you want
that's what people do just to have the
experience like yo I tried it same
reason people eat Kobe beef like like
taste the flavor or the difference like
yeah most people probably could
but you don't you just heard the word
[__] and you're like oh it's
expensive
so with most people with these this hash
it's like dude no no this is a different
like this is a different level of hash
and plus I love OG is my favorite thing
in the world so I'm being biased so but
there's none of you a [__] I got high
school high I a second I was done I
filmed it by the way we'll film into
this Vlog is it drippings
sweat red just
Rose took a dab and was asleep within 15
minutes she got on the couch started
watching someone on her computer me and
Jay were filming I looked back done gone
completely sleep
bro that hash is another level so it's
worth it no never nothing's ever worth
that but I will say it's worth trying
gotcha
if money isn't mean anything to you yeah
that's insane but if you have a like you
know if you're going in with homies I
can see that like y'all put 40 on that
all right I'll put 50 on that okay let's
try it that's that's reasonable for
y'all to take a fat dab like we tried it
that [__] was fire I get that but you
got to basically know a guy to even get
the shot
no they carry it because it's probably
gone now but oh yeah oh really I didn't
realize like yeah they carry it gotcha
yeah I thought that was something but
anyway
I just I oh [__] was so damn good so far
and uh
yeah I was supposed to film it was
Cleveland I didn't really funny of
course it would be that I hate talking
hold on did they say going into it that
you're we're going to be on a stream or
was it just it was a stream thing I
didn't know I was supposed to be on
stream
it's kind of a fine line when my ride
wasn't there he's supposed to be there
and he was out of town okay so if he was
there he would walk me right in yeah
yeah to the way they were going back
time to sit right here you didn't get
miked up oh he's a show he does concert
running he's an artist he knows what
he's doing
it was kind of funny it wasn't anybody's
fault the camera got dead he didn't know
what was gonna have he just knew to let
me in I was supposed to be will uh
Taylor Gang the manager and I didn't
know shots of tailgating the other day
posted me was just the caption goat
that's awesome [__] was sick as hell
um they were cool shirt One champion
Woods came through too yeah awesome
um
so yeah I did that that was real stupid
but something I was thinking the other
day I don't
like meeting new people that much in
case they're mean and I [__] get
pissed
so I feel like I've developed an anxiety
of
people and crowds and [__] I don't know
why I just always feel like someone
might be I just don't want it to happen
because I don't want to get pissed so I
don't like talking to that many people
when I'm going to filming [__] I'm never
let's just say I'm not gonna say who but
at TED Talk
a man and or woman
when we were supposed to go up
this is how passive I am and I went hmm
me and Marty were supposed to go up and
one of the talking people speakers at
the TED Talk
that was going up behind us thought that
they should be going up next and when
they said our names the person went oh
[__] that [__] I'm next
brushed right through us
and walked right up the stage and
grabbed the [__] mic
I could have went
stupid [__] dumb guy I'm not gonna let
you know if this guy or girl
um get the [__] out the way but he was
like you know what
I'm not gonna go in there with this
energy
and then they went up there and gave a
[__] Elementary High speech and said
like and um 77 times I'm not trying to
downplay anybody but if you're gonna be
a [__] to me I'm gonna call you out a
little bit your [__] speech was
terrible but I'm not saying ours would
admit this [__] but grammatically
correct
pauses were their pauses are supposed to
be
and don't say multi-millionaire 77 times
at being a multi-millionaire I'm like
Ugh that is 70 times dude anyway
um
perfect example of a do your thing don't
worry no I'm good I gotta stop doing
that
I like I don't let people run I'm not
saying that I'm like I'm very
unconfrontational because I don't want
to get into the argument because I also
like being mad yeah once I get mad it's
like the [__] remember the fat kid
and hook good rolling ball get him on he
starts rolling and knocking that's me
it's like bro once you start me I'm
gonna go insane on you not like beating
you up but like I'm not my brain's not
gonna let it go because you were so mean
to me that I got pissed you know how
long it takes me to get mad you did some
stupid [__] so that's what I mean like I
don't like that
filming [__] I won't be because I could
have went to the Ted Talk guy but hey
this [__] just brushed past me
tell this people to get the [__] out the
way it's our turn we're next I could
have did that or I could have said that
you were being super understanding
already yes I could have I could have
did that but I was like you know what if
you feel the need that to do that don't
give your [__] speech first it's
totally cool
but I'm saying like in filming [__] like
I could have walked up like yo we're
next we need to go can you uh please
have this person move but like for the
filming thing I could have walked up to
somebody that worked like hey I know I'm
supposed to be over here supposed to be
Wiz right now
um can you please direct me to this
manager who I'm supposed to talk to I
could do that whole route and it was
professional I wasn't mean but I don't
even care like to be direct like that
like I need to stop thinking like that
yeah and I just start doing [__] I've
never done a promo like yo what's up
guys brand new checking out my new video
our new shirt dropping today swipe up
bro swipe up on the news I mean we just
dropped the shirts I just post a picture
go ahead and your shirt dropped I'm
never the one I I feel like it's
rapper [__] where they go like this I
feel like when you try to get away
that's how I feel we've talked about it
before so what I mean by that is
I need to start begging the initiative
to do [__] yeah that's all like
everywhere we go John they ask John what
do you do he's like oh dopestop.com
actually alternative camera John's on it
yeah people ask me what do you do all
the time I go I don't do production I
always said do production just like
freedom of commercials and stuff
I never tell anybody what I do I've had
I've had the guy that worked at work
from my house helped me for like six
months had no idea what I did I just
told him to do production and then one
Daytona was like my [__] son was
watching something and it was you oh
yeah I do you I do videos yo what was so
funny I laughed I watched the whole
thing with him like thanks dude I just
need to start talking to people without
my fear is like oh you do cannabis like
yeah so why are you [__] looking at
me like that that's what I'll say like
yeah what the [__] is something
different now because I'll get pissed
like what well yeah cannabis the [__] so
I don't like to say it because for the
chance of somebody to be like Ugh to you
[__] you're drinking yeah I'm gonna
bleep that word too [__] that one that
one spikes YouTube for sure
there you go Canadian [__]
um
yeah so that's my fear is like don't be
rude I don't like to talk to anyone for
the fear of like don't be rude to me
[__] isn't that so stupid I'm so
afraid to get mad I'm at the Hulk like
yo don't do it please I don't want to be
mad today because I was just getting mad
yeah I mean that's fair because we
people listen to this upcoming story
time they're gonna understand oh yeah
people be shitty to you yes your
entirely yeah so it's like just brought
you I'm doing it yeah because now I'm
not a kid anymore now I'll I'll [__]
bite you or or something like
[__] because as a kid I'm like
okay I'm lit like I can't do [__] to you
but now it's like don't be rude to me
yeah you [__] [__] so that's all
that's all um
you're the nicest person on the planet
walking around yeah but don't be mean to
me I didn't do nothing do you that's all
that's that's what I mean so that I have
that fear of it so coming back to what
I'm saying I need to start doing more
[__] so buy more [__] I mean like we're
doing like I was hosting the smokers
club I was just like standing on the
side of the stage like hey what's up
guys let's just yo talk do some [__] uh
I don't know I feel like I'm always so
no you do it I don't want to do that
[__] yeah yeah
just just super good just be it by
yourself over here in any situation yep
and I like if my friends were famous
rappers I would never be on stage with
them I'd be outstanding smoking a joint
yeah but it's like yo I love that song
but I just like Ugh
no I'm good I don't want to be out there
I it's like I developed an anxiety at
like 24 when it started like years a
couple years ago like I don't understand
why but I was always so fine my whole
life just talking when people were mean
and now that people are nice I'm like
I don't understand my brain yeah but
like even at the meeting I walked out
and saw all those people I even got
overwhelming
[__] all these people over here [__]
female see me what the [__] this is too
much I even felt like uh it feels weird
when people like tell you you do good
[__] uh taking like a comp or good thing
is very odd is that weird no okay so
it's hard for me to just like thanks
yeah
I don't know why why is that I mean how
often do people give each other
compliments face to face genuinely in
life anymore never but at the increase
uh every single that's what I'm saying
but it's it's fine I'm stoked but at
first I'm like oh yeah like thank you
because I almost feel like is it dude I
was just just taking videos I'm glad
that you love it so much and then it got
to the point like bro
you love [__]
Full House and you're a kid have you met
[__] you know what I mean Johnson he was
like bro I love your [__] man thank you
like okay so that's what I'm getting at
I need to start doing more things with
the long forms doing more things if I
dropping your shirt like yo what's up
guys new shirt just dropped check this
[__] out blah blah blah blah I feel like
I'm like a rapper doing that yeah you're
just promoting my [__] yeah that's how
deep it goes in my brain no I totally
understand twerk I don't even want to
put myself out there unless it's a video
and a video it's fine yeah but if I'm at
a restaurant or not I will never speak
to a human in my life yeah but at the
meet and greets I'm open because
everyone's there and I know them yeah
they know me especially and they're not
going to be mean to me so I was like I
love being greets yeah you're all going
to be nice right but like at a
restaurant I didn't want to turn the guy
next to us but don't say nothing stupid
of me dude please don't please be super
nice I'm the same way but it isn't it
isn't out of fear of them being mean
though that's how my brain works like
don't be means that I'm gonna be mean I
don't like that feeling it makes me feel
like I can't like
like if I get pissed I feel like
but you're like walking around with that
yeah I feel like just [__] pissed I
mean that's a weird feeling
and there's no reason for that anymore I
get high for a living there's no reason
I should be pissed but it's got to the
poor where I'm like I don't want to do
anything because of that like I'm
tripping so what I'm saying is what do
you do I get high as [__] on camera I
have a [__] podcast I make clothes
and do a bunch of stuff that's my answer
from now on gotcha people I said which
elevator pitch you're too [__] modest
like I don't want you to talk to me I
don't want to talk about it
but then there's if another person comes
in yo what's up
and I'm all excited and screaming and
[__] yeah different well you know you're
on the same page as them first thank you
that's gonna judge you
no that's what it is maybe it's not
being mean to me they're just judging
the [__] at him yeah they don't want to
have to defend uh all this weed [__] to
a [__] stranger the last time I did
that was with my doctor when she said oh
I'm not gonna see if you smoke weed
whatever I told you that Darkness she's
gone now but she that was the last time
I got in a [__] battle with somebody
I was like [__] I didn't call her
everything except a cuss word I was
really going hard on her made her feel
stupid anyway
um I don't like that feeling
the last fool I worked with we did that
every day remember I told you before I
worked with a piece of [__] I used to
work with that's probably where I
developed that [__] honestly oh cause
I'm telling you like every day I'm like
every time I said something I'm like
it's just looking at all butt hurt and
pissed I'm about to [__] argue with
him right now you can [__] kidding me
so it became every time he came over I'm
like
I don't talk about anything
um
don't even talk about it because you're
going to have an opinion sit around into
a [__] argument yeah yeah so it's
like you don't talk to you I don't talk
to anybody and he got to the point where
I was like that's probably what it did
it so that [__] [__] my head
up I was like bro just get away from me
please I don't talk to anybody yeah
that's how I felt it makes talking to
people a real [__] like effort hassle
that effort yes but when it when they're
cool I know they're gonna be nice and
[__] easy perfect
um I don't know how we got into that
subject but
oh Wiz Khalifa I didn't say anything I
should have said something like hey guys
nicely I think I'm supposed to be I'm
Thomas Brian said yeah supposed to be
will and Dan like oh oh yo yo right yeah
I am on your list that's why people have
managers and [__] I know but you know
what I'm saying yeah that's how I feel
feel like why not like when I get dude
every time I get out of my car at a
valet and fools are staring at because
the car I look straight down
I've never looked up at anyone I feel so
odd it's like crossing a street as a fat
kid's like take your shirt off across
the street everyone's staring at me
that's how I feel like
but a TED Talk I was fine all these
people staring our [__] hyped for us
to be here but at the restaurant I'm
like yo 90 [__] four percent of these
dudes like this little fat piece of [__]
look at this car this [__] dab on
that [__] car [__] you that's
probably like damn all these people
probably just [__] out of me so that's
how I feel dude I hate that [__] and I
guarantee 90 of people's win bro it's
not what they're thinking no wait that's
what I think all the time oh I guarantee
people have that like yeah
self-conscious judgmental voice yes I
have that from being a kid dude it's so
weird it's like
you're not even it's it's one thing when
you're like yo you fat kid you're broken
[__] it's like damn fool
you just you know what kind of car you
just hopped out of just hold your head
up it's still never like them like
every time I go somewhere I'm looking
straight down I'll be in the car and
people stare at the cars like but don't
look at me fool we can judge the [__]
out of me I don't know it's so dumb bro
but when I'm smoking a joint and
chilling I don't give a [__] stare at me
isn't that dumb
it's the weirdest show it's the dumbest
thing my brain is going back to like uh
being a little kid Fool's making fun I'm
like oh I bet you they're making fun of
me it's like anxiety yeah it's so weird
that it came back as I got a holder in
the Maybach you'd think I think you
would have changed no it doesn't change
it's a good [__] lesson yeah
nothing's just like this goddamn [__]
unless you do yeah unless your brain
does and that's what I've decided to do
I don't give a [__]
as I get out of my car now that's what
I'm gonna start doing yeah what's up man
yeah this is my car I earned this [__]
it's my [__] or when people look at me
in gas stations I'm like what are you
gonna say to me and they're like yo nice
car I'm like thanks man I'm always
thinking the opposite uh-huh
always surprisingly oh you're shocked
thank you yeah yeah thanks dude all the
time it's the worst [__] yeah especially
in that car everyone's like your dad
bought you that
you look like a little kid
always always
if you're only new
oh my God
so that's why I'm like [__] but I gotta
start thinking like that I gotta stop
dude that's why I don't talk to anybody
that's why I don't do anything in any
spots I don't talk to her like I've
never joked with a waitress I've never
even though I'd be like that shit's
[__] hilarious yeah I could totally I
just don't show that only roads when
they leave them I go back yeah stupid
[__] I don't know why dude my brain's
always done it I need to stop doing it
because I don't know it's just different
I need to stop it's for everyone out
there you're not alone I do the same
[__] and I am not 15.
I've been doing it since I was 15 though
[__] I don't know it's weird it's a
weird
thing in my brain but you have kids you
can't do [__] like that I do [__] like
that all day long damn it nevermind so
once your kid's like no I see look at
the [__] so I just have to change myself
so I decided that I I talked about it
like three days ago like you know what I
just gotta start doing [__] that I want
to [__] do I want to go do that I'll
just go [__] do it
and the thing is like talking to people
I'm just [__] talking to you if you
don't let's move on I just can't let
things when people have rude to me I'm
like
[__] I have to feel like I have
to beat you into the ground you gotta be
like but I can't but also it's gonna
drive me nuts all day that I didn't do
that to you I'm sure a lot of people
went yup yup
[__] it sucks yeah
normally people are nice though these
days right like yeah every no dude
nobody's been rude to me yeah bro no
one's been rude to me at all no out of
all you know cashiers no not Roots it's
not friendly when you're not friendly I
take it as you being rude
and that's stupid but I'm just like yo
just be nice man
you own this place how long has it been
since somebody just said some [__] to
shut though a long time so that's why
I'm like you know what dude deal with
the ones that are bad when they come
and just put dude when I go when we go
anywhere with John I already know like
okay so I don't have to speak one word
tonight we're gonna get through
everywhere we need to go we're gonna
meet somebody they're gonna give us a
deal we're gonna be best friends John's
going to get their number they're going
to be smoking the dopest by the end of
the night because John will make that
happen in four minutes yeah hey what's
up man where you from well you gotta get
out of there he's just that guy he's a
[__]
I will talk to all of you that's John
and I used to be like that when I was a
kid after a while fools are just [__]
with me
though yeah and then it then it came
back and then just went away
and now it's like yo but leave me alone
please leave me alone I don't know why
and I I it's that for the past few days
I'm over that [__] I'm I gotta just get
over it dude yeah I like my car you guys
stop looking straight down when I get
out of [__] valleys I'm like hey
what's up yesterday I was in [__]
rodeo and I was like
because the dude next to me had my car
but the little brother yeah the older
one he was an older man and I was like
ah he's gonna be judging and talking
[__]
let's just get my car leave so that was
a 40 minute about nothing talk but I
hope a lot of you guys related to it and
I hope you think if you do think that
way it nothing's ever going to change it
with kids doesn't change it growing up
doesn't change it no matter what [__]
car you have doesn't change that [__]
you have to change it and I am on the
way to changing it all right I'll start
telling fools yeah I do you know I do a
show they do a show 90 hoopers I've ever
been to one Uber I've ever talked to
what I actually do one and it was the
Super flamboyant game Max gonna do the
other day because he was just like
[__] going in talking to him like
he's like thank you for talking to me
you do you're very good at like all
right that's what I do for a living oh
really your therapist I go no I just do
like a show he goes oh makes sense you
talk to people all day yeah I interview
people and that's I didn't tell them the
name of it I didn't say anything further
than that but I was like you know what
that's the most I've ever talked to a
person I do
do I talk about weed [__] because then
people start talking [__] see then like
why would they they probably smoke
see I gotta stop doing that everybody
Givenchy in Vegas as soon as they busted
out all of them were like yeah I smoke
oh I smoke oh I don't know if I put my
blast but yeah we gave him all this some
[__] after work
and uh yeah so it's like if I would we
would have never known that if they
didn't say some [__] I would have never
said a word pay with my card
just walked out never you would have
never knew so that's how I feel about it
and uh I hope it helps you guys and this
story time hopefully you watch this last
one I think I'm gonna call it addiction
watch this story time I'm just trying to
change the way I think because I'm now
my age nothing has changed in my head
I'm still seven in my head when certain
things I see them the same way
but for what reason
you know what I'm saying that's all
one million percent yeah so we gotta
change that [__] up you gotta reformat
that [__] if it's not working you can't
be walking around with goofy ass [__]
going on
yes no matter how buff you get or what
car you get or hear me or if you have
children at a sick house
your brain's still there it's still the
same when you were 14 unless you start
changing yourself so that I am on my way
to changing it myself because I gotta
stop thinking isn't that sound insane
Marty it's real though isn't it insane
you know if I [__] wrote that on
paper like that's not true
like bro yes you would think when you
were a kid once I get all this [__] I'm
gonna be [__] feeling myself riding
around oh no no no you know you would
think yeah dude I always forget what
Carmen and then people are looking at me
and trying to go oh he has the car why
the [__] you staring at me I always
forget I'm like oh yeah and I'm like
[__] yeah it's like a little video game
still I'm on like the same level like oh
yeah but I'm also I saved I'm also up
there I forgot I was over doing this
dope [__] I always forget about that I'm
like oh yes car's tight
I don't know I'm just trying to never
like we're always trying to do more [__]
so it's never like sitting there going
oh let's go enjoy the car today like
enjoy the car drive the car and go get
[__] done what the [__] are you doing
but also like maybe there is a day where
I can enjoy the car and go like get a
juice on the beach and [__] like I've
never done [__] like that in my life
might be kind of cool to experience some
of those Matrix things you know what I'm
saying where they're like yo you want to
have steak and sit there and a girl in
the red dress but you know what yeah let
me look at the beach for a while sick
I don't do things for myself ever I just
work and if not I sit at home like
figure out stuff on the phone
you know you're a no but tomorrow
Marty's breaking his Matrix are going
back
the look at his face just went
I don't like it
something you hate Buffalo you're just
like I have [__] to do right here why
would I go back right now but you go
back for a good thing you actually like
this person and it's her wedding yeah so
that's and you're filming the wedding so
awesome and as soon as you're back we're
back on schedule we're booking Cheech
let's go we got cheats coming in we got
John coming in and we're working on go
tag Mexican OT I want that full sitting
right here
full for months and then the other day I
heard a song on him and he was on rap
caviar and the second I saw that you had
a song in rap Cavern I'm like oh that's
it all they needed was people to hear it
just like our show we just need you to
listen we just need to get in front of
you doesn't matter if you know us or not
maybe you'll like it maybe it won't but
nine times out of ten you'll probably
hang out with us
it's like that but for music yeah for
music like yo you just need people
listen rap caviar is a great spot for
that he's a song with Paul Wall I was
like bro this is the song that's gonna
get Meg's going to be so popular
so popular because now people know if
they hear that song they go back and
you're like how have I not heard this
[__] there's a 12 [__] songs they're
sick we want them on the show we need
them on the show please go tag them on
Instagram big response so let's let's
get it done yeah drop a comment on that
[__]
anything else oh yeah drop the comment
of your Instagram name on this video One
winner is gonna win like a 300 gift box
we'll post on Instagram go follow our
Instagram once again dope's usual
podcast also Twitter dope as usual right
and we got the 50 flash style going
we're gonna keep that live till just
past the episode once these items are
gone they're gone gone 50 off of all of
our gear right now we're just we're it's
stupid but we're losing the over a
dollar on each shirt it's you know we
made our money back right it's fine it's
like for a couple days it's only for a
couple days it puts all the third
inventory left it's okay hey all that
inventory you're gonna sell you're gonna
lose money like [__]
and ship it in time you know what we
need new gear let's just stop what we
have we're gonna New Gear that's what
we're doing right now go take advantage
of that [__] guys thank you so much go
follow Marty's Instagram Marty made it
go follow his Instagram right now
Twitter same thing
yeah
oh we have a tick tock dope as usual
yeah I'm starting to post on there dope
as usual I'm growing all right tick tock
and most importantly dope as usual
podcast Clips go follow it go help us
out
um we're trying to get remonetized to be
erased on our videos
yeah you know the whole story thank you
guys my Instagram dope is Yolo dope
period as you know what's on the screen
in topazole all right Snapchat Tick Tock
Twitter all that fun stuff we're pushing
for it feels so good to be pushing all
on all our own [__] we just got
monetized on Facebook we got the tick
tock going dope as usual on Facebook it
was your Facebook yeah it was just a
podcast I don't know we'll link it dope
as usual podcast all right it's Facebook
thank you very much we got monetized by
an app which is nuts thank you guys
um anything else Marty that's it thank
you guys I appreciate it 10 years like
so happy that this is how it worked out
and I appreciate everybody all those
nice comments really keep us like super
motivated and keep this [__] going
guys thank you so much for being here
this has been another episode of the
dope's usual podcast this is Mario
O'Neil I am Thomas whatever you want to
call me I'm pretty high but you know
what's funny the second we press stop
Nikita's outside I'm gonna go open the
door I'm gonna film a bong video so if I
look a little high in the entrance of
this video the intro of this video it's
because
this just happened all right oh we get
high out here okay here that's what I'm
trying to say Marty thank you so much
for being here see you very soon back
from Buffalo guys thank you so much for
being here this is another episode of
the wjo podcast have a dope ass day
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you